to
welcome everybody
to a very
zen
off the rails
this is the uh aromatherapy
uh session of h3 tv april 13. upper
rails what off the rails today's
off the road whatever yeah off the rails
uh peace and love
on this very special calming day of h3
tv sponsored by not the reels
off the rails
sponsored by curology honey and liquid
iv
thank you
before we begin
i just think that it's been a while
since we've had a staring session
with brazzo brazzo of the healing gaze
so i think before we get into the
apology tour
everyone's mad at me again
is that title do you think it's uh
cancelled again again i got cancelled
again again in all in all caps yeah
again yeah
so let's just have a healing session
here oh i need to play this right yeah
okay so here guys take it away bro this
is barratzo
[Music]
for those of you who don't know
[Music]
he
has a special ability people pay for
this
[Music]
he's a guru from croatia
he heals with his gaze so let's just
have a gazing session here today
before we begin to yeah
so cooler minds prevail just gaze into
the eyes of bronzo if you would please
a moment of silence
go ahead and take that full screen
ian
[Music]
that's all
this is not helping
with peace and love zach now is not the
time for machine guns what's the hacking
dog none
poor dan
zack even during the bronzo healing
session dan is getting death threats god
damn
all right
back to the healing please i need the
healing i need healing after that what
happened to you ab why you have ice on
your [ __ ] you got punched in the neck a
long week
wait what happened to you i mean
obviously it's training i pulled
something i don't know i didn't feel it
because i went two more rounds and now
i'm in a lot don't get dude you're so
close don't get injuries now
yeah it's not a serious injury no okay
i'm gonna save a serious injury right
before the day before yeah if i need a
bail i have it on good authority though
bronzo can heal uh yeah yeah hold
muscles just stare at your screen yeah
all right this this one's for abe's uh
healing it's said bratzo's gaze can heal
cancer injuries
um
dental arthritis dental pain
spiritual pain that's true
it's said his gaze is so powerful it can
uncancel people
oh wow which is what i'm hoping for
today here okay
that's great to hear
so okay thank you brought so
yeah people you know what's interesting
about bronzo for you guys who don't know
he does uh he tours
and people pay to
to pay to to to gaze but he figured out
well why don't i just do it on zoom this
was before the pandemic i'm pretty sure
he's just he's been doing the live
streams yeah he's like yeah he's like
actually
you could just pay me and i'll and i'll
show up on zoom and gaze at you through
a computer pretty epic
it's interesting how the gaze is able to
you know work digitally yeah it
transcends uh
the uh
electrical signals traveling around the
globe
[Music]
so
all right thank you brought so
[Applause]
thank you so much
oh by the way this wasn't the tick tock
we posted today it's pretty funny just a
little something to get you in the mood
here's me trying not to get canceled it
does look like me
i'll i'll admit that
he's a little bit bigger for sure but
this is me trying not to get cancelled
it's just not enough lift
it's not enough lift
at the end of the day is there
i love how he just t poses he's like
please take me god
not enough lift i just want to say thank
you whoever sent me that i'm so sorry i
have no clue who sent me that i tried
looking you know i've seen the video
before but i never
connected the dots that it does look
like me
so this is perfect
take me god
hands out jesus take the wheel
in the arms of an angel not enough left
it's just we need a bigger boat
all right let's talk about the
elephant in the room
last episode people got really angry at
uh
let's say i made a joke that james
charles was wearing a diaper because
he's a bottom that i guess made people
angry and then
a caller called in to explain why
why that whole thing is offensive
and i made uh insensitive
remarks and jokes to him
oh god my name is trending i told you it
happened
oh it's moon night that's that's good
wait what
because ethan hawks and moon night
yeah i thought it was youtube it's not
you well i see ethan hawk and then i see
me though
yeah there's too many famous ethans
nowadays i can't even own my own
cancellation
damn it mr hawk
so
by the way that's a pretty good show i
watched it last night pretty good moon
chance yeah
you know like i've said on the show i've
been i've been kind of off the marvel
thing for a while but i have to admit
the trailer for it looked interesting i
like oscar isaac he's uh and ethan hawk
is awesome too yeah sure ethan please
stand we've been watching atlanta that
show's amazing atlanta yeah i haven't
watched it i've heard it's good it's
really kind yeah
i'm pro i'm putting off the
the inevitable here
so here's the thing like
i'll be honest when i talk to the caller
i just
i don't know why i just couldn't
really
i don't know why i just couldn't really
understand but
after
i after the episode ended i talked to
some people that i trust their opinion
who have good inputs about this stuff
and they explained to me kind of what i
said was offensive and uh or they
explained it to me in a way that i
understood and kind of what i said
wasn't appropriate and all this and
you know they they re they explained to
me that i should probably apologize and
explain why and i thought that you know
i understood so
this is my heartfelt apology which i'll
read to you now
after consulting with people i trust
who i value their judgment
to my lgbtq plus fans i am very sorry
for comments on today's show the
sexualization of gay men and grouping of
tops and bottoms is a stereotype that
i'll be trying to unlearn
and apologies to the caller too who i
shouldn't have pressed inappropriately
i hope you guys know i always mean well
so that's my apology
some people accept it some people don't
that's fine
keemstar of course
has my number
keemstar a great ally to the uh lgbtq
absolutely
you know this this this man is on the
always been on the right side of things
though keemstar is addressing his one
lgbtq fan
he says to my lgbtq plus fans he's not
sorry just sorry he got caught bro i'm
on a live show what do you mean i got
caught
gotcha
got you i'm on my own live show i gotcha
it wasn't like a hot mic moment i'm here
right right i have been caught in 4k
keemstar who
oh oh is this a new one i haven't seen
this
ethan clyde has lost his mind have you
guys seen his comments on gay sex just
watch this t-channel for the clips oh
he's denied he watches
the show come on bro we know
i keemstar
you know the bad guy would never say
anything this horrible
i was
legitimately offended and i'm not even
gay
for everybody asking for the clips i
don't even know if i should tweet it
it's that bad
he was just like questioning this guy if
he was a top or bottom and the guy was
saying he was uncomfortable and ethan
was like pushing it
and saying [ __ ] i know why i know why
you are and he was basically making fun
of him because he's gay i swear to god
it's like so bad
oh there's a seven and then the seven
minute compilation
yeah so
shout outs to our great champion i don't
even see those either yeah i think
straight out of his journal
he's so sensitive he's so woke now all
of a sudden i love that for him
i hope he keeps that energy yeah i'm
proud of him
showing a lot of girls showing a lot of
growth yeah he has shown a lot of growth
this this is good takes by keemstar
i really like this new world keemstar
hopefully this is a permanent change
but
having said all that you guys
and
what i'm about to say now
having said all that which i generally
feel and especially you know
i was very insensitive to the caller
the whole pushing the comments
specifically where i was like i could
tell what you are based on your voice
whatever very very gross and bad okay
like i totally acknowledge that
um and the whole bottom diaper thing
okay i get i i understand now like what
i said was offensive but
there are certain things
i just gotta be real about
i gotta
speak my mind on
because as you guys know the minute i
stop speaking my mind and being genuine
is when the show [ __ ] dies okay
now i've been forceful
i've been emphatic that
like cut two weeks ago i got a semi
canceled for the will smith dick
i was emphatic that no matter what i'm
gonna always speak my mind
i'm gonna be true to myself
and i'm not gonna let any anybody or
anyone kind of uh change course for for
what i think is right and so there are
some things about this that really rub
me the wrong way
let's start off first of all
with what dan said
dan told everyone to [ __ ] off and
unsubscribe
i understand that made some of you guys
angry but i have to defend first of all
a lot of people have been calling dan a
horrible homophobe and that's just
[ __ ] that's just outrageous
anyone watch the show knows that dan's a
good man and i'm not gonna [ __ ] stand
by and let people malign dan like that
that's just [ __ ] insane
i gotta stand up
for my boy here
you know so much so that damn poor dan
just made a twitter how long ago was it
two weeks ago two weeks ago you deleted
twitter right i'm out you logged in
today i mean i i was i was sort of uh
harangued into uh making one anyway but
you were enjoying it you were tweeting
enjoying it but yeah the thing is is
that i
i get uh
very argumentative with people and
um you know
and i do want to say i i appreciate you
saying that ethan i do think that um i
did not articulate my thoughts very well
the other day and i i apologize to
everybody that you know
i think a lot of people that i was not
referring to thought i was referring to
them here's what i want to say dan
before you get too deep into that
apology sure
i do want to give you the chance to
speak but
i just want to be fair to dan because
i'm going to say things that i don't
think he'll say
for himself
every week we get [ __ ] canceled and
called out for something that we're not
good enough for we're not woken up be
better it's always be better do better i
feel like an abused [ __ ]
stepson sometimes
you know trying to navigate this space
it's like every week be better you got
to do better you got to be better
um i'm doing my best here guys like
y'all can't f i'm getting like woke
whiplash and it's like last week or what
the will smith thing or there's people
like well sometimes the people take it
too far but this time it's right this
time it's serious or last time is
[ __ ] serious it's like you got you
guys got to [ __ ] like understand
how
intense it feels on this side when every
week people are whipping turning
something
we said into evidence that we are
intolerant pieces of [ __ ] you know or
it's always like oh the veil is down i
always knew they were racist homophobes
oh we can't pretend now to be woke and
all this [ __ ] and dan is [ __ ] sick of
that [ __ ]
and and understandably and we all are so
his snap judgment is like you know [ __ ]
you guys just shut up and you know
people are calling me homophobic dan
knows i'm not homophobic okay he's
standing up for me which it which he's
being a good friend and a good
a supporter so you know
so i totally understand dan's reaction
to say you know
just shut the [ __ ] up and unsubscribe
which you know obviously he was heated
at the moment
but too heated understand too heated
okay
but understandably you know it's it's
it's not
sometimes it just doesn't feel
reasonable with the woke whiplash we get
and uh i understand because like i'm
sorry but me and dan both know we're not
homophobic okay and i just refused i
refuse that title i do outright for both
of us it's just not the case
go ahead dan if you want to say anything
oh
i mean
yeah it again i think that
a lot of well so there's two main
things that people were really mad at me
for one was what you're talking about um
which
uh
again i i think i overreacted i don't
know it was just a mood thing and like
you said it it really wasn't even about
that particular thing but i mean anybody
that frequents our subreddit or goes
into the comments section of youtube
knows what you're talking about and and
you know it gets exhausting to to just
feel like you're
every week people are saying you're not
good enough people are getting better
yeah and so you're better yeah it's like
i'm trying
yeah and i was trying to stand up for
you a little bit um i am glad
that you acknowledge though that
you know especially the the thing with
the caller and and pushing him when he
had established a boundary uh i i didn't
like that that happened either and i'm
glad that you see that that was too far
and that you accept that the other
criticism that i have been getting
which is really the reason that i was
like you know what [ __ ] this whole
twitter thing is that i at one point
during the show was mocking the caller's
lisp
i
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about that did not happen that did not
happen
and if you're saying that happened uh
you are either dumb or just being
disingenuous i i don't
know
what you're talking about there was a
moment people said you were mocking yeah
there was a moment late in the show when
we were talking about all somebody had
left uh i believe it was after somebody
left a super chat telling us that we
suck or whatever
um and you know i think i did a voice
that was more so just like a annoying
whiner voice you know was sort of like i
was mocking and somehow people connected
that to me mocking the caller's lisp
which the caller happened like two hours
prior to that so it's really a leap to
think that i was referencing that
and uh that was really upsetting to me
because i would never [ __ ] do that
and you know again
that just that does not feel like
people are being genuine i don't know
how you can watch that and and make that
conclusion if it came across that way to
people and you genuinely thought that's
what i was doing
i i apologize that that was not my
intent by any means well part of my
problem dan is that people are making
turning it and making a lot of bad faith
arguments that are just total [ __ ]
right yeah so that that that ass the the
overreacting and telling people to [ __ ]
off
you know i accept that that was that was
over the line the other stuff uh
i i don't even know one thing that i
didn't appreciate that a lot of people
were saying
about me is like the only reason you
felt comfortable asking him if he's a
top or bottom is because he's gay
and that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
i ask everybody uncomfortable questions
and that was always that was the point
that i articulated very poorly i admit
but that
this this is this is what you get with
ethan man like this is he pushes
boundaries and he pushes buttons and
it's not targeted yeah that was one of
the top comments on that video too ethan
is indiscriminate and who he pushes
exactly
and you can think that that's rude and
over the line and you might even be
right but you can't but don't you think
that it was targeted you cannot draw the
conclusion from one thing that like oh
well i'm just targeting this man because
he's gay that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay
anyone who watched this show
as that comment well stated it says that
i'm indiscriminate with my inappropriate
questions yes that's how i [ __ ] talk
to people on this show i find it
interesting to make people squirm a
little bit or make uncomfortable ask the
questions that you know you shouldn't
right in real life i'm not like that but
on the show when i'm trying to [ __ ]
entertain you this is an entertainment
show by the way i like to create these
situations i think they're interesting
and oftentimes people love you for it
and but you know you're not perfect but
there's there's people that aren't
familiar with me on the show and they
see that and then they make this whole
grand [ __ ] thesis about how i'm only
comfortable doing that because he's gay
and that i'm just i'm sorry but i reject
i have to [ __ ] i'm not gonna just sit
there and let people say that [ __ ]
uncontested
and i'm sorry to do this
but this was the like
colossal bad take of colossal bad takes
in my opinion
now this is ken
cat 10 barge who i don't have a problem
with her you know
she wrote the article about david dobrik
in the insider
you know she seems to be a good reporter
in that regard and i
i really have no problem with her
and i just don't understand how someone
could actually
think this
and i saw this echoed
by a lot of people adam mcintyre you
know
a friend of the show said newest hd
podcast has so many homophobic
undertones okay
that's fine
right
so okay you know that's a fair statement
but then ken kat goes
to purposefully and knowingly recruit a
queer and gay fan base
so i first of all what the [ __ ] does
that even mean like am i what do you
mean i'm purposely and knowingly
creating recruiting a queer
what am i on the fl what am i handing
out flyers uh my run am i targeting ads
to gay people what the [ __ ] are you
talking about that is just so insulting
to me like what the [ __ ]
what have i ever
knowingly recruited queer gay fan i just
find that statement so foul
i'm sorry yeah it's foul
but then she continues just to [ __ ] all
over them and perpetuate horrific
stereotypes about gay men as a choice
now you may not be first of all you may
not like
a horrific stereotype about gay men i
think is like that they're p words or
groomers like [ __ ] you hear from real
people right now today in florida saying
like uh
they're saying oh you can't talk about
gay people in school because they're
grooming your children that's [ __ ]
horrific
let's check our tone a little bit what
the [ __ ] did i really perpetuate a
horrific stereotype
i don't i don't know i just i like if
what i did was horrific then what is it
they're doing
like can we have some some levels here
right
some
we need some levels am i per you know
let's say okay what i did was horrific
top bottom stuff whatever
a joke in poor taste
genuinely i would like to hear what cat
describes as
like every mainstream conservative
describing gay people as groomers
is if
so what is that
we got it we need some levels here but
okay that's not even the problem she
says
uh perpetuate horrific stereotypes about
gay men is a choice so she's saying
i've gone out into the world i have
recruited queer and gay fan base
to and then i put him in a room
and and now i'm i'm going you're [ __ ]
the worst
so i've i'm taking them and i'm beating
them up
how how can you watch the show if you
think that about me
this is what i'm saying some people i
think are too sensitive to watch this
show
so i'm never going to be i'm trying my
best i'm always trying my best and i
hope you guys know that i always mean
while i'm trying my best but if you
think that i'm this horrible this is the
worst [ __ ] if this is who you think i am
how the [ __ ] you watching this show
to purposefully and knowingly recruit a
queer and gay fan base just to [ __ ] all
over them and perpetuate horrific
stereotypes about gay men is a choice
so there you have it
i am choosing to
i'm sorry but this is [ __ ] insane
thing to say pub i mean i'm sorry but no
i just completely refute it
uh without reservation just a hundred
percent and i'm sorry cat
to put you on blast but you know what
i've i saw this echoed i read the
comments and i personally just found it
a horrific
accusation
and it's and it's gross it's just gross
and i don't even know what it means i'm
still baffled by what she means by
purposefully and knowingly recruit a
queer and gay fanbase what the [ __ ] are
you what does that mean
what have i done to recruit gay fans
i i don't know i i how do you even do
that i don't know what that means
genuinely either
um how
i mean we we do have a significant
uh
fan base um
like uh but
i i don't
we didn't go out of our way to recruit
them i'm happy they're here yeah we're
very happy they're here and i'm glad
that they enjoy the show 100 i'm so
happy
listen i don't want anyone to stop
watching the show okay
and just make that very clear and the
people who were offended who are able to
continue watching the show and to
understand that you know
we're doing our best here and we mean
well that's [ __ ] awesome i love you
guys
but um
i just i don't know i found this take to
be just a little bit vile to be honest i
i don't know
but i have no problem with cat and i
don't know why she's
got to take it like gotta go nuclear
with it
but there you go i mean she's been on
the show you know friend of the show
apparently i will
apparently or
was i don't know i mean she's a critic
of this space uh you know and that's
that's what she specializes in she
writes on it
and certainly she's welcome to have her
opinion and voice it but
yeah of course but but yeah i mean in
this case i don't know it just seemed
like you said well it's like you need to
go nuke that that hard with it seems a
little overboard well it's like you said
she's a critic she this is her specialty
and so i feel the need to respond
to such a strong
strong
accusation that had some
steam to it
you know i'm sorry
but
cat i don't know what to say
painful
so there's that you know
um i have some notes here there's a lot
of stuff i want to talk about
um
you know
and a little and you know i
i don't want to
part of me from this like
whiplash i i
i do feel like there's a little bit of
like
the left eating themselves
because if cat is we're best at
yeah i mean the left really eats itself
that's a
long running and and it's and it's
actually it's really painful to me
because if cat thinks i'm that big of an
enemy
we can never be allied
can never be on the same team as her and
just going through this these past
couple months of like every week
something happening it's like it really
makes me understand how people like tim
poole and steven crowder and dave rubin
and all these [ __ ] goons on the right
that are just vile freaks that you know
i despise on many levels
i understand how they exist and why
people why so many people watch them
it's because they get tired of being
called racist and homophobic
and they say you know screw this i'm
gonna go hang out with these [ __ ]
guys and it does radicalize them because
once you you roll in that crew
it's hard to get out right
it's hard to get out i'm not i think
that those people were always spineless
and that's you know but the audience
there's there is like a certain thing
like it'd be so easy for me now to be
like
go on tin pool or whatever because they
always invite me on now whenever this
[ __ ] happens but like ben shapiro used
to always try to get me to come on the
show every time i got cancelled and then
talk about how walk culture is the
[ __ ] uh you know ruining society i
never did i always said [ __ ] you you
little bitch-ass weasel because he's a
piece of [ __ ] and i'm never gonna
i'm never gonna go that route right
yeah no but it'd be so easy to go there
and be like you know what blah blah blah
what culture this and that and then the
you get new fans you get a lot of new
fans and then all of a sudden you know
you've got to start catering to them and
you get sucked in and once you go
against them because they're they're
just as bad as like the ultra woke they
have these the dog mud that you don't
[ __ ] cross too well you're right and
then you wind up like dave rubin where
exactly hero is telling you to your face
that he thinks you're evil for being a
gay man and that he would never come to
your wedding and exactly you and you
just knock it and you not alone and be
like okay well i accept that i
understand you end up dave rubin totally
and i could have there was a path that
could have taken me down to temple dave
rubin
sure but but i chose not to and i never
will i never will because i know in my
heart that those guys are [ __ ]
reactionary pieces of [ __ ] and i hate
everything they stand for it's against
everything i believe in
[Music]
but i get it right because y'all
when you're constantly calling people
gay or homophobic and racist and [ __ ]
who
mean well
maybe they're ignorant maybe they don't
they're not like totally they're not
like ultra woke but they mean well
they're definitely on your team like
let's be honest
like me and dan we're on your [ __ ]
team there if you don't think me and dan
are on your team you have no allies you
have you there's nobody left to fight
for you
if you think that me and dan are are
actively
homo like again there's like okay i
understand i can hold some like
homophobic uh
like to say oh you think it's okay to
make that joke it's like i get it i you
know i won't do that again i understand
that it was offensive but you you this
label of homophobic and racist if you
think me and dan are not on your team
then you [ __ ] there's nobody on your
team
there really isn't
i'm sorry but me and dan
are two very progressive dudes very
social conscious dudes dan more than me
who's been called a homophobe probably
more time in his life than ever before
is that right dan
probably the first time yeah first time
yeah
and like it's one thing to criticize
someone and it's another one another
thing to like outcast them
to [ __ ] uh exile them
which is what it feels like sometimes i
mean we had people returning their teddy
fresh because of the show it's their
choice we give them a refund i totally
get it but it's like you want you don't
want to be associated with me anymore
i'm that [ __ ] nuclear to you
okay
i mean it's a choice but yeah that's
it's a choice and i and wait and i say
you know and our policy is we're very
sorry
you know take your money back and we do
a full refund we don't we just are very
polite and understanding it's totally
fine i understand i'm just saying
that
you got some of y'all think you're doing
a good thing genuinely
but i actually think that a lot of
what's going on is making things much
much worse not all of you because i
understand that's why i apologize right
like there's a genuine space for an
apology and understanding and learning
some people take it away too [ __ ] far
and it makes it way way worse
that's why i showed kat's tweet i don't
think she's i think she's making things
worse what takes like that
like i'm just sorry i'm not choosing to
recruit gay people for the specific
purpose of offending them with horrific
horrific
stereotypes horrific
that's a strong word don't you think
just saying
it's a little hyperbolic just saying it
is very hyperbolic a little hyperbone i
mean you gotta hold you gotta save words
like horrific for
[ __ ] that's horrific
you really do
you know what i mean yeah just saying me
making a a offensive joke is not
horrific i'm sorry
i've seen way worse i've seen way way
worse
okay just being real just saying
you know
yeah i'm glad you said though that um
you know
the the the tim pool the the reactionary
oh i got canceled so [ __ ] all these
people root is is not in your heart um
because i think it's important to
to state that and let people know and i
mean i feel the same way no no amount of
people accusing me of being a homophobe
will
prevent me from advocating for their
equality me neither like but some people
it sucks to hear yeah it's painful it's
painful to hear but
um
i will
fight just as hard for you as i did
on
sunday as i will today of course
of course me too
but uh
but it i see the path you know where
you're like there's this group of people
with open arms like one of us right
you're one of us again it's because yeah
i mean i i white grievance baby come get
it i don't think they ever
felt
as strongly uh as they claimed as they
may have once claimed to or whatever
yeah you know like tim poole claimed
they just i was uh i was a liberal
for years but they've been they've
they've driven dave reuben too yeah both
of them i used to be a liberal and then
people called me racist and now i hate
myself for being gay
right agate you know flaming turd bag
[Music]
but i'm just saying white grievances
baby it's all right here
come ye straight white men
we take you with open arms you are the
real victim of society
of course i think that's absurd right
but i'm just saying
you guys aren't some of you i'm not
saying like all people who were upset or
offended obviously but some of you guys
make [ __ ] much much worse by labeling
people homophobic and racist who aren't
i'm not going to accept that title i
agree that i have tendencies and stuff
that i'm working on
you know what kind of [ __ ]
relationship are you in where it's like
every week you're not good enough every
week you're not good enough that's an
abusive relationship
you're not good enough be better you're
not good enough be better
you're not good enough be better i'm
sorry but i'm open to it i'm doing my
[ __ ] best but like at a certain point
it's [ __ ] just it's not healthy it's
[ __ ] up and yeah that was what i again
very poorly art was trying to articulate
the other day that you know if you find
yourself watching the show and being
upset
every week
after every episode you turn it off and
you're just like
you know
this is my heart sank at everything he
was saying and
and you know
it's just so upsetting
just just step away i mean like i was
trying to say i mean it just might it's
probably healthier for you to not watch
something that upsets you on a weekly
basis almost on a daily basis and by the
way that's not to say we don't want you
here i would love for everybody to watch
and for us all to grow and work through
stuff as i try to mature and you know
you know buff out my rough edges
whatever
without changing my you know
fundamentally who i am which makes this
show good most people like
but
yeah without saying like hey [ __ ] you
and you're the worst which maybe that's
how it came off it's just like
there's probably different shows for you
that you can watch and not get so upset
you know just saying
thank you
yeah i mean horrific i mean what's
happening in ukraine is horrific
what's happening right here is horrific
what's happening in florida is horrific
what's happening with abortions in texas
is horrific yeah
oklahoma just yesterday right the day
after we talked about it at length uh
um
passed something that just pretty much
outright bans abortion
um
that's horrific yeah what happened to
that lady who had a stillborn in texas
that's horrific
right
i don't think what i did was horrific i
i don't
and i'm sorry if some of you all [ __ ]
want me to you know
cut my
[ __ ]
wrists open for you and nail myself to
the cross
but
like i i'm both sorry and trying to do
better and also denying that what we
[ __ ] did was horrific it just wasn't
it wasn't horrific
okay and i'm sick of [ __ ] feeling bad
every week
like i goddamn
strangled
like i threw a bag of puppies in a river
or some people do
and that's horrific that is perfect
people do that
why do they do that that's not i don't
know some people they don't want the
dog's litter i've heard that they do
that and they put they stuff all the
puppies in a bag and throw them a river
it's [ __ ] horrific
right
i'm not doing that
pretty awful yeah
look at these [ __ ] freaks i just
wanted to show you guys this in case you
all forget what actual homophobia looks
like and again i'm not saying you can't
care about two things at once right
what i i did do some things that were
homophobic or like you know a little
ignorant let's say
but this is [ __ ] happening right now
grooming look at this [ __ ] this is
horrific groomer grooming groom rumors
groomer in chief grooming rumor groomer
grooming groomers grooming groomers
groomer grooming grooming groomer
grooming grooming groomers grooming
rooming grooming grooming groomer
groomer grooming groom rumors grooming
rumors groomers grooming groomed
groomers groomed grooming grooming
groomer grooming groomer groomer
grooming grooming room grooming grooming
grooming grooming groomers grooming
grooming rumors rumors
media fully backs this pro-grooming
position
okay
that's horrific they're talking about
the don't say gay bill in florida where
you're not allowed to talk about
that gay people exist because it's
[ __ ] grooming kids that's horrific
these people are ghouls these people are
sub-human [ __ ]
this is disgusting yo that's homophobia
just saying
that's horrific
right and again i'm not saying you can't
care about two things at once but like
if what i did was horrific then what the
[ __ ] is this
and you're just saying that there's
there can be a little bit more nuance
than
just zero 100 yes
because i agree i'm on you guys aside
this is [ __ ]
this makes this is so vile it's just
i can't believe that there's a whole
media machine
uh trying to in this year 2022 uh uh
categorized gay people as groomers
and isn't it [ __ ] ironic that most
these people are like conservative
christians you want to you want to find
groomers all you got to do is look in
your [ __ ] back porch at the church
[ __ ] like start there if you want
[ __ ] i can't get over the fact that
these people love to call gay people
groomers and then they go to church on
sunday and their [ __ ] kids get
molested by the priest like [ __ ] you
republican uh
leadership of tennessee i think it's
tennessee just passed a law allowing uh
marriage to children
what yeah do you not know about this
hold on the [ __ ] do you say
child marriage law
uh like literally at the same time that
they're uh
oh apparently oh just seven hours ago
failed to advance i guess there you go
that's nice yeah uh
okay well that's a that's a dub that
that didn't uh get through but it's
interesting that it didn't turn into a
big talking point because
people were trying to counter the the
whole groomer narrative by pointing out
that like
this is literally going on how do they
not care about that those dudes in your
party want to marry kids
i don't know
that's what i'm saying it's like insane
yeah it's it's hard to square that
circle so you know like and i i this
this to me is important personally i
[ __ ] find it repulsive it's just
disgusting
um it's it's
it's medieval i mean what the [ __ ]
you know this kind of culture war [ __ ]
just makes me sick
so i don't know
i think that's pretty much all i wanted
to say about it
so you know on one hand
on one very serious hand i do apologize
and on another hand you know i do feel
like i need to
defend
myself and the show
and dan in this case specifically
uh
and that's it you know so you know
what else is there to say
ian thoughts thoughts i'm just kidding
anything you want to add in
[Music]
what are you afraid of ian come on ian i
know you want a piece of the action
ian doesn't get mad he just he gets he's
disappointed
no remember ian's the zen god ian's
practically brought so back there he's
just he transcends can you get the zen
music and cut the end please
no he might have to cut him he ain't cut
the end i don't know if he's doing it
ian cut the end
[Music]
that's bronzo not ian cut the ian that
appears to be brought so
[Music]
thank you
oh that's trippy
a little bit try to match up your eyes
yeah just a little bit lower
yeah yeah yeah
the eyes are close oh
i love that just a little bit to the
side
i
whoa that looks crazy even has the
little bonsai tree in the corner you see
that i'm telling you this guy's zen
that's awesome i'm gonna go d
d tier
all right so there you have it if you
all want to [ __ ] cancel me again for
what i said be my guest i got nothing
else to say about it
i mean the reality i'll do another
apology next week
we'll get the podium ready
oh yeah i forgot about our apology
podium well the apology podium is for
sarcastic apologies
when it's a real apology you know i feel
like it's a little inappropriate
we'll have the podium next week
[Laughter]
all right well
uh
dan zach and k you guys went to a
concert last night hell yeah we did
eight times we saw king gizzard and the
lizard wizard oh that's your [ __ ] dan
that's my [ __ ] yes and i dragged cam and
zach along because uh
because i wanted uh them to experience
uh the glory and i knew those two in
particular they're both into that type
of music and i knew they enjoyed it and
you guys did right i mean you guys had a
good ask dude we had a killer [ __ ]
time nice they sounded great i mean like
the rhythm section was on point the
whole band uh a lot of great uh h3 fans
came up to us oh that's awesome that was
the reason i put it in there is i wanted
to shout out everybody we ran into it
was like i i've outside of like the
teddy fresh pop-up i've never run into
this really the king gizzard the giz
head we gotta we got the lab in the
audience oh man i'd love that dude dan
almost got into a fist fight last night
wait what well
it almost tell me tell okay
there was this like acid looking santa
claus [ __ ] like he had like
these like braids and his stomach about
to hear and like
he he was tripping on i mean he was
[ __ ] up and clear was [ __ ] up he
smoked like three joints in the time
yeah
was he a fan of the show or he didn't
know you no no no definitely not he was
a gizz fan and the whole night he wanted
them to play as one song rattlesnake
okay and he's like every [ __ ] slime
they did like a two-hour set like after
every song he's a rattlesnake he did a
free bird kind of thing yeah and then
they closed with rattlesnake
and he's so [ __ ] hyped he's like slam
dancing but the pit was moshing in front
of us but he wasn't in that this was
like the you know stand-up kind of
groove section you know he was [ __ ]
like slam dancing and during the
breakdown of the song he started going
like
he was [ __ ] straight up doing like he
was miming snake [ __ ] because he was so
hyped so there was playing there was one
point earlier on in the set where he
kept bumping into me so i kind of pushed
him
and then dan kind of did the same thing
because he was just [ __ ] getting in
our space and [ __ ] and he was just not
being courteous at all it wasn't really
even a push it was more just like hey
you're like
laying on me practically at this point
and okay
i shoved them i didn't give a [ __ ]
this guy was jumping up and down all
show like okay
i quickly separated from the other guys
and just did my own thing because i
couldn't stand standing next to this guy
so wait get to the park i'll get to the
part where they almost
did you tell them well all it really was
is i i
several times had to keep pushing him
off of me and then at a certain point
it was so odd because he he was like so
angry but also polite at the same time
because he like stepped aside and like
made room for to to get in front of him
so that he would stop bumping into me i
was like oh cool thank you and i stepped
past him and then as i'm stepping past
him he's like do it again yeah his eyes
were like coming out of his head like
he's like dude and he he was tripping he
was like
do it again man do it again do it again
i was just like are you like it was
really [ __ ] loud so i like wasn't
sure i was hearing him right and again
it was like coinciding with like a
polite gesture so i don't i don't i
don't think he even knew if he was mad
or not but anyways
were you were you going to get his back
if he got jumped i mean
oh for i whispered him i'm like i'm like
are you good man like this guy was
shorter than that he was straight up
like 70. like i wasn't really he was 70.
he was an older he's trying to fight you
know yeah he was going to be able to get
his last [ __ ] he was being he was he
look there's there's courtesy man
there's curtis when we go to a show sure
i get it yeah but i'm i'm he's like dude
again i'm like all right you want to go
down dude
more than me yeah i want zach to have my
back if that [ __ ] ever goes down but and
then we see him outside of the concert
and he's like i need two man for
santa barbara man we're going to the
next show he was like like almost like a
dead head he was very tired
yeah but king giz had no king lizzie
dead heads aren't supposed to be violent
no no no no not at all i don't know it's
he he was with his body and he's like i
need two for tomorrow night man they're
going to play rattlesnakes
so anybody he's going for me oh go ahead
he offered me a hit of his joint at one
point and my instinct was to say yes but
then i realized that this guy looks like
a wizard on a bender you definitely
don't take a joint yeah from a guy that
looks like that that is laced with some
stress yeah but you know you know how
like christmas like halfway in july he's
like july santa claus
he's bizarro santa claus yeah yeah yeah
he's june 25th santa claus he's staying
a cut and loose during his vacay he was
[ __ ] but i'm a good ass time i want
to thank dan for the tickets there you
go grove and we we really had a great
time and thanks to all the fans again i
mean yeah probably
i don't know like 20 people approached
us at various points dude we gotta get
the king gizzos yeah the gizzo like even
when we got in line first they're like
oh my god what's up guys and like you
know every second we arrived people were
coming up to us everyone was super sweet
super nice and that's awesome good old
time yeah there you go you see love them
rattlesnake the troopers
[Laughter]
oh i gotta give up to either real fast
tomorrow the april collection is
dropping
you can find this hoodie
it's got these pull strings dope
a dress
made of terry
dope
uh shorts made of terry
sick this dude is
we have we made underwear for the first
time oh no way yep we made underwear oh
i gotta call that so there you have it
hanes baby
teddy fresh is haynes wait is it i don't
know no i'm wearing paints now oh you've
just taken over yeah
no it's it's made by us this is what i'm
wearing
really nice i love that uh
you're wearing the chanel patch you got
the undies on no i don't i didn't get a
pair yet
you know here it is
it's all happening at teddyfresh.com
and if i do say something offensive we
do accept returns
so you can buy you can buy
with a clear conscious that is it a
valid reason to return
it's okay
um it's all happening
at teddy fresh
did you say when the when the drop is
happening tomorrow tomorrow at 10 a.m 10
a.m est 10 a.m which is when all drops
happen thursday at 10 a.m pst
i felt post malone rocking that last one
in a music video i don't know did you
yeah i saw him wearing wait recently i
can you find it recently let me oh
that's so nice she's supposed to he's a
sweetheart he's still
he's still he's got love in the nation
yeah yeah he still reps the niche he's
he's just a busy guy he's a busy guy
this is an awesome ila shirt it says hi
mom and on the back bye mom by the way
we did a photo shoot which was cool we
me and hila haven't really ever done
that for the new collection which we got
some cool photos from like you guys as
the models
for our socials sure
very cool that's cool yeah that's cool i
took a real i took one which i think you
guys will like i did this was my idea of
course
it's me with the high mom shirt looking
real serious
and then in the back and then i turn
around to show by mom and i burned out
the back of the um of the pants so it's
just my ass is showing no my bare ass
no way are you
you're not [ __ ] around no we did that
yesterday
i was in the backyard burning a hole in
the pants
so it's like hi mom all business
all serious and then when i turn around
you can see my bare ass through the
pants that'll go up tomorrow my ass
looks crazy bro
and that it's just god
i had to warn everyone i'm like listen
everybody
i'm coming out just so you know
if you're not comfortable seeing my bare
ass now is a good time to avert your
gaze because there was a whole crew
there
everybody knew that everybody knew so it
was just like everybody just
everybody just know what's going down oh
my god that is so funny but i burnt i
burned it like you could see my ass
cheeks and then my thighs and it looks
like a perfect
like
corner
it looks gnarly my ass is so fat
bro get your [ __ ] ass up and work
wait what happened to lina maybe
i don't know if that's a spoiler alert
you can say okay
uh lena didn't know that there was that
little cutout thing oh stop lena i
announced it to everybody no not about
you okay yeah so i don't want anyone to
think that i like came out with no no
without telling anyone
so wait what didn't you know about
well i don't want to spoil it i think
this part might be a spoiler it's not
there's no spoiler okay so theo mooned
her
oh teddy moon yeah he did
well that's funny
because my ass no intentionally yeah she
didn't know it was out she started
cracking up teddy kept being like daddy
why is there a hole in your on your
pants
because he was down there the whole time
we did photos with him too for the
family
oh yeah lena was here she got to see
theodore dropping f-bombs right lina
lina that's correct she said that's
correct yeah
i
i didn't know that the teddy mooned you
[Music]
at the photo shoot yeah
yeah we just walked in at the wrong time
i guess
but teddy pulled down his pants and
showed you his butt
no
he didn't she didn't know that there was
a hole in it and he turned around and
she saw yeah
what my ass
your son
wait when did my my there was no hole in
my son's pants no just ethan's
wait i'm so confused oh no i'm confused
i thought theo had over so confused
okay maybe i'm wrong then
wait
dude you you had to know that my abs
coming out with my ass out lena
i didn't i didn't know what was
happening at that time just theodore
wanted to see you so i took him into
that room and we were like oh
so yeah
all right get the apology podium out
so theodore told this story to lena
theodore said my dad's butt's out that's
what happened
i swear to god i was like
everybody
my ass is out now's the time
i said disclaimer guys everybody knew
what was happening
now i've sexually assaulted lena
yeah we just did harassment training the
other day ethan what the hell yeah we
did that dude i literally was i couldn't
have disclosed it more
no you did you're right and i saw you
when you guys were in the backyard
burning the shorts too so i knew it was
coming but i didn't know what's going on
at that moment
god so you came out and saw my fat ass
well it's about to be all over twitter
apparently yeah yeah it is it's going to
go up on it a whole lot of other people
dude that sexual harassment training we
had had like an all-star cast it was
crazy it was crazy you [ __ ] ross from
friends was in it and uh i was like in
there like harassing women yeah for real
what did you learn
um
me and zach need to
turn it back a little bit we do we have
too much uh secret tickle time we gotta
come back
that was a little far
by the way here's post malone in the
shirt so god bless so i guess maybe
there's something coming out that's
awesome love that sick
great guy
great guy
one of the best a member used their
resubscription message to say uh title
the next episode i accidentally flashed
my employee gone wrong canceled again
again i know that i feel bad now leno
had to come out here and [ __ ] army
weinstein
god damn it brian kavanagh is a force of
nature
can we talk about ryan kavanagh please
get on to some
um okay so with all that being said um
we got probably got to thank our
sponsors we are
almost 30 minutes over
and then we can get into what we got
here oh yeah you got you ian and cam did
a segment
dj khaled's walk of fame that's right
and i can't wait to see that you i can't
wait for you to see it so let's do that
let me think oh and then corporate date
the guy who said cutting onions is for
betas yes he [ __ ] got arrested for
for kidnapping kidnapping and human
trafficking like two days ago in romania
right on monday in romania yes evidently
yo this is so [ __ ] interesting
because that guy's been on
rollo tony browntown
fresh and fit
uh michaela peterson dated him and said
he's a great it didn't work out when
they broke up but he's a great guy great
guy i need these people
these conservative family value [ __ ]
well probably not fresh and fit and all
those guys but michaela peterson
definitely you got to explain to me
you got to disavow
this
human trafficker kidnapper
he was he was he got charged for
imprison kidnapping women and forcing
them into prostitution like real human
trafficking [ __ ]
yeah which was something that he had
admitted to doing proudly in the past
evidently uh we found evidence of that
uh roi baby
yeah well this is going to hurt his roi
jail time will hurt was bad for our yeah
not good you're not good
not good uh i think we need to pressure
all these people to respond to cobra
tate
this is this is this is what their idols
are doing literally human trafficking
so crazy this is crazy yeah i mean it's
[ __ ] is [ __ ] up as [ __ ] obviously i
mean it's like uh comic book villain
[ __ ] yeah
well anyway uh let's thank our sponsors
real fast we'll get into the walk dj
khaled walk of fame thank you to the
wonderful curology
love curology
guys if you want ultra easy skincare
that's actually made for your skin
curology is the way to go you'll get a
custom prescription cream made for you
by a dermatology provider for your
specific goals whether that's tackling
acne clogged pores skin texture dark
spots fine lines or something else
you start by taking a short online skin
quiz you send them pictures of your skin
and if it's a good fit they will
prescribe you
and ship the formula
right to your door now going to
dermatology is a pain in the ass you
know if you want to do it through your
insurance provider they gotta like refer
you
it takes months
it's a whole thing man
but this is actually cheaper faster and
easier and i love their products i use
them all the time i'm a huge fan of
curology they also send like uh
with the custom cream they sent a face
wash
and a moisturizer that i'm addicted to i
i don't want to use anything else now
that those two products are
great um the skin wash doesn't leave my
skin feeling super dry and the
moisturizer doesn't leave my skin
feeling super
you know greasy it's really perfect
products i love this product i really
use it every night
highly recommend it get started with
curology just like i did with a free
30-day trial at curology.com
h3 just pay five bucks for shipping and
handling that's c-u-r-o-l-o-gy.com
h3 links in the description to start
your 30-day
free trial cancel anytime prescription
is subject to consultation thank you to
curology you know um you love them
it's honey
today's episode sponsored by honey the
easy way to save when shopping on your
iphone or computer that's the new thing
they got it on the iphone now
you know
shopping online is awesome i think most
people buy stuff online now the great
thing about that is that there's always
these coupon codes and discounts which
are paying that's to find them
so what honey does is it scours the
internet automatically finds the promo
codes for you and and applies them at
checkout it's a no-brainer
way to save money it's incredible it's
an incredible free service super easy to
install then you got a saving thing for
us
thanks to honey manual searching for
coupons is a thing of the pack what the
hell 300 bucks
these are all from ela these are all
from my wife ela she just drops them in
the chat for me every time she gets one
what the hell did we save 300 bucks on
let's see the 300 400 uh right i think
it was a big couch that you guys bought
right but that's like 10 boom
yeah i mean that's really good
and it's it's so easy it's free shopping
tool
you know imagine you're shopping at one
of your favorite sites when you check
out the honey button appears and all you
got to do is click apply coupons wait a
few seconds it's honey searches for
coupons you can find for that site funny
finds a coupon you'll watch the price
drop
magically you don't even have to think
about it dude thank you steven
see i wonder if steven feels about us
just using that now on all of our
sponsors
we're monetizing his ass
honey doesn't just work on desktop now
it also works on your iphone too just
activate it on safari on your phone and
save on the go so if you don't already
have honey you could be straight up
missing out and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
the show i wouldn't recommend something
i don't use so get honey for free at
jointhoney.com h3 that's joinhoney.com
h3 thank you thank you thank you
and finally liquid iv
this actually really helped me out when
i was sick the liquid iv
it's great
it's got uh
it's great for working out
meditation yoga walks
just waking up in the morning
you know or when you're sick
when you have diarrhea and you're
[ __ ] out your brains and you have no
liquid retention
it's got everything you need to get back
on your feet because it's got all the
electrolytes it's got all the
all the stuff in it that makes
makes it good you know
for example it contains five essential
vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c it's
got three times the electrolytes of
traditional spore strength it's made
with premium ingredients it's non-gmo
free of gluten dairy and soy
oh chantelle's into a liquid ibiza she
has one every morning that's awesome
yeah she loves the product i do too it's
a great great product
they've got a bunch of flavors
watermelon lemon lime strawberry pina
colada more
they've got like a hydrating formula an
immune abuse formula
and a cat and a boost energy boost with
caffeine so if you're not into coffee
it's a great way to start your day
it's an awesome product man really is
uh grab yourself
some liquid iv in bulk at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
and use the code h3 at checkout that's
25 off anything you order when you use
the code promo code h3
liquidity.com experience better
hydration today
at liquidity.com promo cut h3 thank you
oh ab is chugging it as we speak that
easy
hydrating one
i actually like the way they do it
because you can kind of like if you've
got drinking like a traditional energy
drink you gotta like carry that [ __ ]
with you or go by these pouches you just
grab a bottle of water and yeah you got
and i drink it right before the gym
because coffee upsets my stomach oh
there you go that's [ __ ] awesome you
don't even have to think about it yeah
thank you thanks steven
thank you steven all right thank you to
our sponsors if you guys uh you guys
want to support the show that's a good
way thank you
let's talk about uh dj khaled's walk of
fame
now what how did you guys capture this
moment ian what's the backstory here
uh we're driving
uh sam and i were driving around
hollywood and i saw this thing sort of
getting set up
for a
ceremony thing and i looked it up
a couple days ago and it was for ashanti
she was getting a star
and then i was like oh that's
interesting and then i scrolled down and
i saw dj khaled getting a star in like
two days
after that
and so um monday morning i messaged cam
and i said
do you want to come meet me in hollywood
and grab a camera and
let's just go see what happens i don't
know i've never been to one before so i
um
we went over there and just messed
around
what was it like being there is it what
you thought it was i've never been to
one either
i was surprised by some of the people um
in attendance just to show up for khaled
so you'll see in the video
you'll see you'll see but the i was like
really they get
this level of you know talent to come
out for these things because dan was
saying you you buy the star you gotta
pay for it right i had always heard that
and so and at i was i was telling these
guys about it i'm like is this one of
those things that everybody says but
it's not true but i looked it up and
sure enough this is from their website
can i buy a star no so here's the thing
you you do have to still be uh nominated
so to speak fifty thousand bro fifty
thousand dollars you gotta give them 50
grand who are you paying well it's an
organization that that runs it you know
it's like a non-profit kind of thing
that in collaboration with the city
uh well there has to be some degree of
collaboration but i i believe it's
independent i don't think it's run by oh
that's the government that's awesome
yeah but it just anytime you see one of
those and the person receiving it is
like this is this is so humbling this is
such an honor or whatever just keep in
mind that that that person paid to get
that
thousand bucks kind of changes the
context
now they do sometimes give
them to people that passed away and i i
don't imagine they hit up the family for
the fifth oh hell yes
but yes they do if you want one while
you're still alive they [ __ ] damn
well dude
of course they do i think they do shake
it down
yes
somebody got to pay for that they go the
50 000 sponsorship fee is used to pay
for the creation installment of the
start man that's just like one tile the
thing is take their money this
organization is they also
maintain it so to speak which means you
know cleaning off the [ __ ] yeah i'm sure
they paid that guy really well well some
money today we're like let's lose some
money today or for example when when
somebody comes along and smashes donald
trump's which is something that happened
repeatedly
i imagine you know they go and fix it
bad roi on the trump yeah yeah oh yeah
they've lost a lot of them not popular
here in l.a yeah
so okay well that's that's that's pretty
interesting
yeah so uh we we've got a video here
queued up um i can't wait all right
should i run it yep please do take it
away
we're hearing beautiful beautiful
beautiful
holly
yeah what was that
uh are you sure you want to ask in the
background of this shot
it's kind of yeah
what's the problem uh it's kind of
gratuitous don't you think get a good
zoom on it actually zoom
zoom it's i'm zooming but you know
there's a straight up
b-hole in there look at that ass it's
art
are you like anti-art
you want to go burn down the library of
alexandria too while we're at it no i
just i just
might be a little risque zoom
focus
it's art
we're artists
anyways
we're here in beautiful hollywood where
the water is flowing freely the land of
dreams and opportunity
and we're here to see one of the
greatest artists of all time we're here
on the hollywood walk of fame to honor
the legend the icon the notorious
anti-pussy eating dj khaled getting a
star
but he deserves the galaxy he's going to
be joining
such an incredible range of talent such
people as charlie tuna hal
fishman
rick d's
the jokes right themselves people here's
the star of my great uncle carrie grant
maybe one day i'll get next to him in
the podcaster legends you could fill a
trader joe's on a sunday morning with
this crowd it's pandemonium anarchy
they're playing smooth jazz they're not
playing dj khaled's music though i was
with you inside the movement original
movement
what are your thoughts on dj khaled
i think he's the best i guess right you
know who he is i do know who he is miami
uh
dade county
i'm not really a big fan of them so this
is dj khaled's first star do you think
they were going to give him another one
yeah
another one yeah another one another one
another one another one another one
another one
yep
another one another one uh we're gonna
get a beautiful view of dj khaled's
lower torso as you can see all right the
presenter is going over his pages and
pages of notes they all say the same
thing this is a major key alert it just
says we the best five thousand times
like the shining there's a whole crew of
of camera
camera people over there
we're put over here with the commoners
uh
which is kind of an insult to us i mean
maybe i can show this photo and they'll
let us in
excuse me my boss met dj khaled once can
we get backstage passes maybe
we are looking for a khalid sighting so
far no luck he is four minutes late
being on time is what they want you to
do dj khaled is 12 minutes late and
counting they're playing wii lobby music
to try and relax the crowd but the
audience is frothing in anger i feel
like he's got to be coming soon there
was just a shift in the barometric
pressure in the area a college storm is
incoming oh is that is that that joe fat
joe is here more like trim joe looking
good there was definitely a trigonometry
used to create such a fine beard
oh
diddy is here
jay-z is here ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
the five foot seven inch supernova dj
khaled is here get a shot of diddy
through her phone i think that's gonna
be our best angle yeah that's a good
shot yeah this is a great shot that's a
good shot right there who the best
we the best do the best we the best who
the best we the best thank you very much
today hollywood honors dj khaled
khalid coming out here looking like a
fresh baked salmon
this is a fantastic shot
can you make sure to get a really good
shot of their lower body
can you get a good shot of that
you see the eggs you got it you can see
the stomach and the legs
no face i'm not a regular type of person
look there's only one calor that's all i
have to say dj cullen
[Applause]
[Music]
i just love dj kelly
what's your favorite dj khaled
catchphrase another one
classic it's a classic this guy almost
let me get on his back but i was like no
i didn't want to break it you know
look they're really nice on a peach
lovely suit i just want to
chop them up and eat them look like a
big old peach for sure dj kelly is a
wonderful spiritual
and earthly human being he comes to my
restaurant sheffield seafood in little
haiti
sheffield
amigos
they call me crazy bobby crazy blade i'm
the one that dj keller wrote the song
about with nifty hustle my homeboy i'm
from rolling 60s and nipsey from rolling
60s and he made a song about me because
some other people tried to lie on me and
nifty hustle and dj khaled wrote a song
about me and i loved him hired by dj
khaled and nifty hustle
and i love them for writing that song
it's a true story about my life
make sure your booty is plump
he's got a big hose and he's patient
folks
i'm going to water his grass soon berkey
used to be a meth head but she conquered
her map our tribe her addiction to
matthew make a difference so
proud you ain't got no money
you ain't got no money think about it
help the families
the climbers zombies
i want to change
[Applause]
i think we know who needs to get the
next star on the walk of fame ladies and
gentlemen
and that concludes the dj khaled walk of
fame ceremony we saw some incredible
legs today the glutes were on fire the
hammies were looking good the star is
there looking crispy no one has puked on
it yet no one has diarrhea on the star
in hollywood fashion it's sparkling it's
beautiful and it's a sign of a major key
alert this has been ian and cam of the
h3 podcast
signing off another one another one
another one another one another one
another one another one another one
another one another one another one
another another one another one another
one another one another one another one
another another one
that's interesting that they cleared out
fast enough for you guys to actually
get to touch the star
[Applause]
uh we well i went back later
that was a different day well that was
later that day yeah that's interesting
though just they cleared out so fast
well wow what a what a segment you guys
loved it that was great i absolutely
loved it
that was fantastic
i was so surprised when like jay-z
started coming
yeah he's busy uh apparently jay-z
doesn't have star surprising oh my
goodness callie got one
that's what about fat joe
i'm not sure maybe they're just there to
suck up to the organization because they
want their own star
well
well and again
khalid might have just been the only one
that cared enough about getting a star
that he was willing to pay the 50 grand
because i'm sure
jay-z's qualified but he showed up
so he cares enough to show up i guess so
i guess so
does it surprise you that khaled has
enough clout with jay-z
to get his ass out on the
i mean
middle of the day i know he's a meme to
us but i mean he's he's a big one of the
greatest industry yeah he's like a
jordan collab he's big
he's big
dxl collab too
well [ __ ] congratulations to khalid
and great job you guys on that in the
field reporting that turned out great i
loved it
thank you thank you i was giggling and
laughing the whole time
shout outs fergie glamorous has been
stuck in my head all day
what's that cam
uh glamorous has been stuck in my song
he was singing yeah yeah that guy loved
the camera man who was that he got the
whole audience worked up he was bigger
star than coward that was buffalo bill's
brother
[Laughter]
well wow what can you say about dj
khaled
is that one song his where he goes bag
alert major bag alert i think that's a
callout song
it's hard to tell because he doesn't
sing in his songs uh let me see
bag alert major badge
by dj khaled it is yes man he got hit
after head another one
theodore sings that song
does he really there was like a popular
meme on tick tock and i was doing oh he
did a few videos to it and now he goes
back bailey bag alert song
bag alert major bag alert
awesome anyway
great job guys
that was awesome
uh
is there anything at the top of the show
that's good before we go on the camera
gilbert tate
uh this incident with ab was interesting
this morning abe saved another family
from a burning car i stayed my family
this time a beautiful wednesday morning
i got a call from lena she said her tire
popped and flew off oh god
holy [ __ ]
that's scary what the hell
i cannot believe that you would do that
to your wife baby
that looks so sketchy
for you to take that kind of risk with
lena just for some cloud on the internet
man i was yeah why did you stab her i
was wondering what was why was it in the
dock like what's the angle
you literally stabbed the tire just
admit it
for clout i ran out of here and i saved
my wife from the dangerous highways of
l.a well but that's oh that's an easy
fix hopefully right
we have bad karma bad car karma in this
group for some reason yeah what happened
you guys started it took it yeah we
towed it it's it's actually good right
now we gotta pick it up after work
oh thank god yeah i was afraid that she
messed up the actual
whatever the tires what is it yeah the
wheel the
rim okay dumb [ __ ] ap
was there any burning families or
anything when you saw that not this time
no okay
well good job bud thank you thank you
uh
oh also the uh the gilbert godfreed
stuff wait gilbert gottfried i mean rest
in peace to a great one
he made a video about mr beastberger
well so he was on cameo and since he
passed away
um people have been sharing a lot of
their favorite videos of his and i saw
this one and it just made me [ __ ] die
it's so funny
yeah
hey mr beast i just ate some of your
mr beast burger
and let me tell you your burger makes
for a better fleshlight than food
i've spent the last 20 minutes [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of this burger and it feels
great
my [ __ ] is so happy
thank you mr
breast the hell
that was well worth the money whatever
that was
he accepts all cameos i'm pretty sure
likely he didn't give a [ __ ] he just
read anything yeah that bless him for
that there's another one in there of him
talking [ __ ] to pewdiepie somebody wow
okay
uh another one about pewdiepie let's go
honor
his memory this is gilbert gottfried i'm
pissing and [ __ ] and coming
this one is for pewdiepie
and the nine-year-old army
i am the come lord
marky player is a better let's player he
loves to drink milk ew he is so strong
and sexy
i'm going to take a [ __ ] now
what if i'm not mistaken max mofo is
behind both of those clips okay
i wish
people are saying
howard uh
he was he was a regular guest on howard
he was on the show like 125 times
uh
he said gilbert was so cheap that he
used like lawn furniture in his house
that he wouldn't spend out the expense
to and he would always ask people to buy
him stuff
my goodness yeah those aladdin royalties
don't pay that good apparently well i
guess he was just so cheap
well he was rich i mean he was very
successful yeah
i wish i had known about his cameo
policy we could have got some mileage
absolutely yeah i mean
keemstar cameos
he'll just read anything
you didn't give a [ __ ]
so what happened uh
hours after he uh sadly passed away yeah
they of course hacked him on
in uh twitter i was i was on twitter and
i was just the guy did he really post
himself no
the person who was being posted
discovered it and was like what the [ __ ]
why is gopro humphries twitter account
posting all my only fans content
uh i'm dead because of you archive on
instagram
what did this count count get banned yet
yeah i don't think it got
banned but it got restored and locked or
whatever
can you look up yeet archive on
instagram to see if they got banned yet
and then this [ __ ] actually put
a bitcoin taking donations and all
proceeds go to the memorial of godfred's
legacy that's insane yeah i'm [ __ ] up
i like saw this
on twitter and my jaw dropped i just
could not believe that because we were
talking about it and zach just saw it
happening in real time he he went to go
check his twitter for the announcement
message and this is what was here i bet
you he couldn't he could have cleaned up
because so many people were talking
about him yeah i'm sure that was the
goal yeah yeah
wow what a [ __ ]
what a piece of [ __ ]
if we have the uncensored i can't i can
check how much they got
yeah yeah actually well don't i don't
want to show the crypto well but you can
look it up and tell me yeah i'm curious
to know what what god's name is this uh
well this is the the gay porn that was
being posted to it we censored it he was
retweeting gay porn yes yeah
what
no shot
this is all censored dan
uh it should be yeah it's awesome okay
jafar that's tasteful of you guys to put
yeah
rest in peace to the goat man yeah
dude
oh i see it's
the guy they put this is so
this is so insane yeah it was pretty
gnarly why the [ __ ] did gilbert
gottfried just retweet my of promo when
after he died
it seems like he archive is still there
it's not deleted well archive the yi
archive
how is that possible i mean get your
[ __ ] together instagram you [ __ ]
i mean they may have not had anything to
do with it and we're just
i think it's coming
oh that's true it could just be a
a troll yeah it could have been intro oh
you're right
but gilbert gottfried famously
had a like
no joke is too soon policy
um so i'm pretty sure he actually would
have found this really [ __ ] funny
right that's fair i mean i'm short of
the fl trying to get people to give them
money well that part is [ __ ] or is
donating because i mean that's just
scamming but okay i i can't i can see
that yeah
he would never read a room either he
would just go in and like the most
uptight affair he would just go with the
most vulgar [ __ ]
crazy vulgar stuff
he famously got uh
before the term canceled was even uh
all right
right
like right after 9 11.
no he went in he he made some like
crashing into a building joke to it
people got angry about that he got he
got in some trouble he was the one of
the first cancellers
well again i mean
cancelled is a relatively well hold on
what was the joke let's honor him here
today it was something about uh
look that up let's let's let's not i
heard it on the radio when they were
talking about him uh it was like um he
also i tried to catch a flight uh
to the west coast the other day but
there was a layover in the empire state
building and this was like
okay wait hold on sorry this is
important
apparently it was just them trying to
[ __ ] with this guy just to clear up the
person
on twitter is not the guy okay the guy
on instagram is the guy because that
page is gone
okay
yep so yeet archive on instagram is gone
on twitter unrelated
yep thank you
also he got uh fired from the aflac job
because he made tweets about uh
a big tsunami that happened oh [ __ ] he
really doesn't miss an opportunity no i
think japan that was horrific that was
that was horrific yeah the from the
earthquake those massive tsunamis yeah
he uh fukushima
yeah meltdown and everything yeah he
made he made some tweets and he got
[ __ ] [ __ ] wait hold on i want to
know what he said
that's bravery right there i don't give
a damn what anyone says that man walked
right in the fire knowing damn well he
would get burned
i want to see his 911 jokes too [ __ ] it
let's honor this man too godfrey's
shocking uh japan tsunami joke
holy [ __ ] this guy he is the
uh japan is really advanced they don't
go to the beach the beach comes to that
holy [ __ ]
uh
i just put up with my girlfriend but
like the japanese sail it'll be another
one floating by anybody oh my god
jesus dude
holy god that's real edgy comedy people
say you're edgy but that's you would
never go there apparently he got fired
from snow only being on it for like 12
episodes or something like that right
really no wonder he's broke you gotta
you gotta admire these guys these
comedians that are just they are [ __ ]
like nuclear because they just don't
give a [ __ ] about
anything like any politics oh avery just
hooked me up with the 911 joke a video
of it actually
oh god in 4k too look at this
i wanted a basically a dressy elephant
in the room
i have to catch a flight to california i
can't get a direct flight they said they
have to stop at the empire state
building first
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ]
dude somebody screamed too soon
wait they did i gotta hear that that's
the question
it was at the roast of hugh hefner yeah
i play that again
oh though i see it was like a subject
yeah yeah
no you're living
wow yeah so
ripped to a legend rip the real one you
gotta admire the man he he he was he was
he went in
and he did it amen
what joke would he say arriving in
heaven what would be too soon
i'm sure he thought of something good
did the pedophiles
make it up here
no
he he'd probably make like some mass
shooting joke
right because that just happened the
other day yeah somebody said please play
guilford godfrey reads 50 shades of grey
i've seen that video it's it's too
vulgar
i mean it's about as vulgar as the mr
beast thing but um
i mean it's long it's just it's
literally just him reading like the the
uh like the bondage scenes from 50
shades of grey i've never read that
stuff it's is it very it's very graphic
eh
uh honestly my only exposure to it is
him reading it it's a little disturbing
the movies [ __ ] sucked
they were bad
you've seen the oh yeah
you've seen them all oh yeah and the
strangest thing for oh hold on in their
sex zack yeah you watched them all how
much could you have disliked it it was
like a hate watch thing
did you ever did your was your dick uh
in your pants the whole time yes okay so
the the strangest thing was to see my
mom was reading the book oh well you
know oh oh boy that that was that was a
little weird and she was reading it
pretty fast
that was interesting man i'm like what
what the [ __ ] are you
like oh it's a good read
i mean you watch those movies and you
give me [ __ ] for twilight zack ah that's
a fair point i'm saying what i'm not
giving you [ __ ] for twenty wait wasn't
it a twilight fan fiction isn't that
what fifty shades of grey came yes
yeah
it's literally uh so bro zack you were
not even you're you're you're a bigger
twilight i'm out yeah
you're not even getting the real thing
you're getting like deluded twilight
time out time out time i know when did i
ever give you [ __ ] baby
because i played the sound bite for a
whole year non-stop how is that giving
you [ __ ] that's just common
i like the twilight movies what's wrong
with that i'm sorry i don't mean to hurt
your feelings i'm just kidding
but yes i watch the 50 shades of grey
movie and yes they're [ __ ] you just gave
me a really clean sound by zach by the
way of the like the twilight movies how
many twilight or how many 50 shades of
gray movies are there three you watched
all three yeah
three or four three three yeah three
yeah yeah it's a trilogy it was so epic
though i watched that just saying
but um
that can you say i love 50 shades of
grey
clean i love 50 shades of grey got it
do your thing
revenge you got your ammo thank you you
got your little uh stream deck
absolutely yeah you get to set that up
with that definitely
time for revenge yeah you're waiting for
this moment but yeah it was very bizarre
to see my mom reading those books
very i mean she wasn't the only one no
no no no no it was like housewife fodder
yeah it's weird to see a son i i didn't
know that like uh the submissive dom
thing was such a popular uh fantasy yeah
yeah eds81 bdsm is that what it is bdsm
bondage because i i i'm not really clear
on the story but what was he doing like
tying her up and whips and stuff or was
it more than that he had this like red
room
which was his like sex layer but yeah
like he would tie her up and you know
but wasn't she like scared of him or was
it just like a romance it was a romance
but
like the first movie you could see her
hesitation and okay i believe again i
haven't seen this in a long time i
believe she leaves him at one point and
then comes back because she's kind of
like okay
i'm a little so it is is it depicting a
healthy relationship or like a really
[ __ ] up one uh
[ __ ] up
yeah you could say that but i mean but
then again who
wouldn't that be king shaming in a way
because like that that is their way of i
don't know i haven't seen it
i don't know
okay
but yeah wasn't here ever wasn't here
her boss
isn't that part of the angle that people
were like kind of upset about it i think
so she worked for like
it started as a fanfic so you know
that's kind of par for the course
did you ever get turned on watching it
zach at any point just be honest with me
no i mean the act never it was so [ __ ]
it's like uh i i don't believe the sex
scene at all
interesting yeah
i didn't i didn't just asking i'd admit
if i was yeah and you know people saying
is a bad representation of the bdsm uh
community
i'd agree with that okay
because of the uh
somewhat non-consensual uh nature oh
there was non-non-consensual
wow well i'm basing that off of the way
that zach was describing i i have not
seen them but
we're gonna have to do a viewing party
you know what we need to do we need to
put like sensors on our dicks
and watch the movie and then
there's there's ways to do that so i'm
just saying and then we can see who's
turned on when
dude you can make that movie like on an
end and then we got to do the same
experiment with twilight is there
is that was there anything about that in
the sexual harassment training
yeah
yeah yeah there was okay um
speaking of screen this is a little bit
of a non-sequitur but long time watchers
of the show will know what i'm talking
about
just last night when we were going to
the concert
somehow it came up and it hit me
we we need to sit down and watch tiptoes
tiptoes
that movie movie no no no wait oh that's
where gary
what's tip though the movie we talked
about it forever ago on the show it is
like a movie from the 2000s with matthew
mcconaughey the role of a lifetime and
and gary oldman is playing a little
person oh [ __ ] and it is like the
craziest [ __ ] movie trailer ever and
we were dying
and somehow i got brought up and i'm
like
if if anybody in the audience is not a
long time watcher doesn't remember what
we're talking about after the show today
look up the trailer for the film tip
well let's watch it now you want to just
watch it yeah i'd watch it you know if
you guys can rip the movie
re-upload it see if it gets claimed
because these old weird [ __ ] you know
what i actually remember we did get
claimed when we showed it on the podcast
they claim tiptoe they claim tiptoes you
know what blew my mind i would watch the
whole thing on a special episode
i mean we could just do that like in on
a thing that we don't think everybody
can dispute it it's you know you don't
hit those babies it's like a bonus bonus
episode i think we got to do that you
know what bloomberg the trailer got
claimed just from reacting to the
trailer i i specifically remember that
happening because we were we were so
blown away because it was like who wants
to claim this can you find at least like
the movie poster
yeah so what gary oldman's just on his
knees the whole time or something yeah
ethan you know what blew my mind cam
seen it he's like yeah that was
triggered at all he was like i've seen
tiptoes i was like no [ __ ] way
tiptoes let me look up the imdb
what uh let's see it's a star-studded
[ __ ]
y'all
are you guys matthew mcconaughey gary
wait peter dinklage is in it yes but not
as the main character that's what i was
saying which is like yeah i mean is that
oh that's gary oldman yes as the little
person bro mcconaughey probably the
greatest actor of this generation gary
and what's so crazy
about this movie is like the seemingly
the entire setup is like
matthew mcconaughey his entire family is
little people like he's the only person
that doesn't that is not a little person
and
that does happen right i mean sure but
like the whole like setup is like the
wife or the fiance finds out about and
she's like
i don't know about that oh and it's like
what like he's like i don't want to have
kids it was something like that and it
also i mean the name itself tiptoes is
pretty bad just everything about it
tipping around on our little toes
people say members only yeah i mean
that's not a bad option you do like a
members only stream that's uh wait wait
wait this sounds incredible
it's so bad oh right they all
so it's a comedy
no no it's like a drama oh shot yeah
it's the role of a lifetime dude the
role of a lifetime that's what they say
oh what oh he's jewish okay interesting
uh twist there
why not jewish little why not it's
matthew mcconaughey
look at gary oldman i wish we could
watch it man why don't we just do a
special app where we say okay he's gonna
get claims who gives a [ __ ] i'm down to
do that i think it'd be fun really or we
can do one off the rails maybe next week
special app tiptoes present h3
production presents tiptoe
i don't even know where we could find
this [ __ ] movie it's scrapped like
i'm sure
[Music]
we'll find it i got it i got a guy yeah
we can worry about it
what ain't scrapped if they're claiming
the trailer
yeah some somebody owns the rights
it's amazon
oh it's on amazon it's on amazon
i think you have to rent it though so
it's not like on prime oh this is so sad
how are they gonna claim this trailer
let me just zip to the middle and see
how the bar is steven's brother paul
all right
he could have prepared us for this don't
you think yeah that's awesome they're
like i was going to meet his family we
were in love and then i found out
they're all little people right but i'm
sure they say like i think
throughout the entire thing they're
calling them midgets
the first 30 seconds of the trailer the
best scene is when like the family
meets kate beckinsale and she's like oh
like she had no idea so let me see like
so look at this so here's gary oldman
that once there's one small problem no
problem
everything was great but there's one
small problem
there's one small problem yo they really
like special effect his ass the whole
movie instead of just hiring a little
person which again peter dinklage is in
this movie who's a fantastic actor like
easily could have played it but no let's
have gary oldman just like crawl around
hi i'm ralph i'm his brother we're twins
are your parents um he's really on his
knees
yeah
yeah
it can tear them apart i think you're
gonna let me know that everyone in your
family is a [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
all of a lifetime baby the role of a
life yeah later in the trailer they're
today
did they really say that yes yes dude we
quote it all the time when they show
gary oldman's picture then wait i got to
see that yeah they were trying to like
academy award bait yes for real they
thought this was they thought they were
they really thought they were doing
something here wait they're here let's
see arquette and in the role of a
lifetime
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i'm sure gary
is sticking back fondly over his long
career
[ __ ] play winston churchill but this
is the role yeah
i love that and in the role of a
lifetime gary oldman
no [ __ ] way
i mean this is like a snl trailer it's
unbelievable it's like it's hard to
believe this was a real movie the
thousands were crazy i think we got to
do this i really gotta do this and i
definitely need that sound bite
immediately okay oh
that's powerful very powerful all right
here's what's going to happen now i got
to go to the bathroom desperately okay
and then when i come back we're going to
talk about cobra tate
being arrested
there's a video and photos and
everything and then we got to mobilize
i we need people to answer for their
association with this guy
we need to disavow
i think it's only fair he's been on
fresh and fit right
he has he has been but uh before we go
too far down that road you know that um
tom and christina also had him on who
are friends of the show so well are they
i doubt they're like well they were like
goofing on him obviously yeah right no
yeah they had him on as he's like a meme
on their show and they ended up
interviewing him the way that we do
sometimes they don't need to apologize
okay fair enough yeah you don't bring
someone on your show and you endorse
them and you don't challenge them right
and you're agreeing with everything they
say you're saying you're the
can imagine fresh and fit actually i
want to find the fresher fit with cobra
tate i want to see how they introduce
him
sure and i want to see and i want you to
pull up michaela peterson talking about
him
and rolo tony browntown if you can find
it that story about michaela is so crazy
too she broke up her family for this guy
and then when they broke up she said
he's you know it didn't work out but
he's a great guy he's a great guy
he's a great guy
that's jordan peterson ladies and
gentlemen daughter
meat eating michaela
[Applause]
all right i'll be right back okay he'll
be right back he'll be right back
oh we're going to meditate while he's
gone
do y'all like my brother poster by the
way
i've probably talked about this on the
show but the dude i used to work for
years ago like did his live streams when
he came to america which is why i was
actually super familiar with bronzo
before ever even
working with ethan and ela i i guess i
remember
they made forever ago
a uh
a video about bratto and i remember
seeing that and being like holy [ __ ]
they know about bronzo um but yeah i uh
i really want him to come to america
like i can't like
if it happens wherever it is we're going
like we have to see this in person hell
yeah i'm down that h3 video you're
talking about for like three years after
watching it i had like this tick
whenever i would yawn
and i'd go bra
and i was holding it right now because i
really didn't have to stretch
but yeah i'm down i mean
my friends group was
like it was like a meme amongst
just my buddies for years we would
always talk about broadso uh like had
pictures of him
well i had a bathroom in my apartment at
one point without even staring at you
while you were sitting
my friends i know what the [ __ ] i was
talking about they thought i was a
weirdo screaming at brazzo when i yawned
right
then do you know if he's coming to
sweden
maybe i didn't i just looked he has some
dates in germany uh
it's not too far it's if you want to pop
over to germany i mean he's in croatia
right is that it well he's based in
croatia but he and he he pretty
regularly tours uh
in europe but he only makes his way over
to america very occasionally and like
when he does it's like a big deal to the
people that are
into that kind of thing my favorite
halloween costume is when i dressed up
like bronzo oh that was good that kind
of turned into a meme too
yeah i still see that picture crop up
all the time
people are
going sorry to interrupt you people are
asking about my shirt no this this is a
batman shirt people are asking
the batman
changing my opinion on the movie tell uh
ethan we want a boss
tell ethan we want a bobby lee episode
um you know what uh it
some things that might be in the works i
was just talking to
his producer george the other day and i
threw out there that you know we're
starting to have him people in person
guests again
and uh
he is uh
frequently requested as somebody to have
back so um thanks dan
god it haunts my nightmares
haunts my nightmares forever
i kind of want to acknowledge how the
chat every time we take a break you see
what they do with different like drugs
like dabs for dan this has been a thing
in the last couple weeks uh it cracks me
back
you back dabs for dan it's like acid for
a b
mm-hmm uh
i don't know what they do for zach
what is that
xanax i get lean
lean for love
it's just like been this meme in the
chat for the last couple what does ethan
get
why you got a freeway don't free
baseball now that we're talking give it
a second we're about to opiates for
olivia that's right for olivia cocaine
for cam
uh dabs for dan or dmt for dan oh dab
like a like a hit of
like a fat load of thc dabs are a it's
like um
is it a dab of type of smoking is it
what is your resin yes essentially yeah
yeah it's like super condensed
concentrate dab
a dab will do you
the dab will do way more effective
i feel like it's all good
characterizations like i feel like a b
would be in the amphetamines dan is
definitely into dabbing
ecstasy has always been my favorite drug
of the ones i've tried
lions for lena
lines for lena mine's for liam okay lsd
for love zozo for zach what's up
because it's a silly zonka drunk oh
you don't want to get zonked ibuprofen
for ian that
is real mild that fades dude actually
the most dangerous probably of all the
drugs we listed you gotta be careful
with that [ __ ] ketamine for ethan well
that doesn't really mean it doesn't
really work
for sam speed for sam speed for sam
that's true gotta go fast
yeah heroin for halo damn
and benzo's for bruce
benzes
oh come on that is two months old
he does sleep a lot though
maybe it's onto something
let's talk about our boy cobra tate go
bruh we had such a fun time making fun
of this guy with brittany broski he's
got to be my favorite alpha male
he did a whole thing about how
um
if you cook your cooking is for
idiots and poor people and loser bettas
and [ __ ] and uh
some of the most unhinged alpha
rantings i've seen what was his other
take that was incredible about
water oh sparkling water a sparkling
water
waters government issued tap water's
government issued
at least that one was that one i gotta
say was a at least a little bit novel
because
intuitively i would think that like the
machismo like alpha guy would say that
like sparkling water is for [ __ ] yeah
you know what i mean like drink the
[ __ ] trap and move on right it just
seemed
i don't know it's like a salt of the
earth kind of guy would yeah just yeah
drink it straight from the hose exactly
just [ __ ] spray that [ __ ] right in
your mouth no tap
tap water is for losers and betas
weird accent
sparkly just drink the bubbles and shut
up
a little bit of a marie antoinette thing
right
um okay so cobra tate
got arrested for human trafficking and
this is incredible happened just a
couple days after
uh it happened uh yes this redditer was
the one that brought it to our attention
so if you go to
this was all shout out basically
provided from this user blue ass water
thank you blue ass water shout outs
uh it's in romanian so basically here's
the article
and he by the way
by the way this is his brother who also
got arrested also looks like a good dude
yeah they live together and apparently
it's a
he
yeah i wasn't aware of the brother but
the brother is equally uh he looks like
kind of morph like this guy
i mean these dudes are
they're not gonna lie they're kind of
scary like
well yeah
they're like involved with organized
crime and stuff too so you know
well i'm glad they're in romania and
rested right yeah they'll come looking
for me dude nobody's gonna pay for my
webcam okay
don't try to put me into like a sex
trafficking i'm not there's no dollar in
me look i think this guy bro
man those guys weren't loved
so
here is a video i'll read the details
here let's see this is all translated
police were informed by representative
of the u.s embassy
about the fact that there's information
that a 21 american citizen
is said to have been abducted by them
cobra and his brother christian tristan
were both arrested oh no they're they
were later released on bail
yeah that wasn't stated explicitly but i
saw some follow-up where uh they they
were
how do you let someone like that out on
bail they're like yeah no we couldn't
have people enforce them into
prostitution they're like okay cool
let's let you out on bail i mean you did
it's
innocent until proven guilty
and still
still applies i don't know well
sometimes they don't know anything about
the romanian legal system whatsoever so
i have no idea after the authorities
searched their home and cars the two
brothers were taken
to hearings
uh but for tristian tate last night
seems
like just a bad memory he posted an
instagram story a video in which he is
filmed relaxing while driving one of his
expensive cars in the northern part of
the capitol whoops
why is that a wubs
like
i i guess whoops isn't the right word
but like
cobra and his brother had their house
raided on monday where police found two
young women held against their will
one romanian and one a 21 year old u.s
citizen yup
what the [ __ ] dude
yeah and apparently in the house is like
set up uh for um
like camming you know it's like it's
what he's admit to on camera right he's
like yeah no i do this this is my
business yeah
here's andrew tate
or i like to call him andrew taint who
got him
thank you
thank
you um
is there any update please tell me
they're not on the streets guys
well sounds like they are
oh god
what a nightmare i mean you know
presuming they actually get charged you
know there'll be a trial eventually and
but
they were able to rescue the uh
well that's good the girls so that's
good yeah i still understand you go into
someone's house you find they have two
people kidnapped and then you let them
out on bail
like i
i don't understand that they're like no
they kidnapped us and forced us into
prostitution they're like okay cool well
you know go go have a fun time guys
sorry but
that that's that's too [ __ ] up of a
crime to let them out on bail
i mean if they really are connected with
organized crime and stuff it you know it
could have been a bribe situation yeah
in romania totally speculating here i
have no idea i don't know
[ __ ] about romania what am i even
watching right now
oh here's the goons the gone squad
oh [ __ ]
he's like do you i bet you guys drink
tap water
are you [ __ ] beta poor people
oh
[Applause]
what is that sound what was that it's a
cobra
oh okay oh
interesting
oh here is uh not cobra but his
brother's uh story
police
oh god oh god what's happening why oh
god
oh i wanna read the story here we go
okay zoom in on that please search my
house found a long receipt a thousand
dollars of women's and children's
clothing
why did you buy all these
to drive to the border of ukraine and
help refugees oh he's a saint oh that's
nice i saw the look in his eyes after
that it was a look that said why on
earth are we searching this guy's home
oh what about the two women they yeah
what about that kind of sidestepping
one of the major uh the us embassy
literally reported that you have a 21
year old u.s citizen uh
kidnapped in your house oh my god
well i i hope i don't think they're
going to be allowed back in the u.s if
the u.s embassy
reported the crime to romania right they
can't just like come here
anymore no more fresh and fit
appearances probably
uh
yeah probably not uh
um
i mean
assuming yeah if that if it was like a
international incident essentially and
the u.s embassy was getting involved i
think that it might be tough to get a
visa to travel to the states after that
let's see oh we got a whole timeline the
tate brothers car searched
a luxury car with two women came comes
out of the villa both hide their faces
there were other women there too it
seems like that the mother
okay this is the mother of the abducted
romanian woman
said they recruited her because she is
too naive my daughter is 20 years old
she is in college
in front of the villa a desperate woman
appears the mother of one of the girls
who was in the villa owned by the tate
brothers when the masked men broke in
explains how her daughter a second year
student would have joined the english
entourage my child is a good child
you nev
she never bothered me i always ask her
if she had a boyfriend and she would say
no mommy i'm just going to college she's
a very good child i think that's why
they recruited her because she's too
naive she told me she was going out for
a drink with friends his streams it
seemed strange to me from the beginning
since i saw pictures of the girl
he said of the guy it seems like the
translation's getting done yeah gender
isn't wrong you're right saw pictures of
the guy that she said she was dating
i saw
that he had a dubious face i didn't like
him but i didn't say anything to my
child she had a dubious face i mean
you essentially said the same thing
about him
i thought
he was a colleague of hers
and then they go out for coffee she
doesn't do anything wrong and that's why
i think clearly the entourage is to
blame my daughter is 20 years old
uh revealed the mother of a young woman
kidnapped by the tate brothers
the woman called her daughter so called
friend fishmongers apparently the young
woman who arrived in the entourage
have been seduced with a career in
modeling
later however it was to be sold in
romania or abroad
according to the woman who was on the
verge of losing her daughter for months
she didn't seem to tell me everything
she was doing she used to tell me
everything she went from several
presentations i think that's what
he does he creates he recruits for naive
girls
from presentations that's what i think
that's where the little fish picked her
up and brought her
this one
i'm trying with the yeah it's tough it's
not it's fine that way he always sends
me pictures look mommy i'm in a
presentation
the child told me everything he didn't
hide anything from me i think she's he
saw she was naive
he wanted to sell her abroad
i know what that means that one comes
through crystal clear
the masked men are continuing their
search the police are searching
uh here's images of the police at their
house
it was a full-blown raid it was like
yeah it was like a whole swat team yeah
christian tate nervous and agitated
while the police are in his house
uh there's evidence raised in a van
police car enters the courtyard of the
villa in which investigators put the
evidence they have gathered
they took computer drives dvds documents
garbage they took a garbage container
cobra tate
pulls a cigar out to relax
awesome
he walks quietly around the house with
the cigar my boy cobra
cobra tate is informed by the police
that he's going to be taken for
questioning he intends to leave with the
cigar but law enforcement warm that he
is not allowed to smoke in the car
the englishman puts out his
cigarette and goes
uh with the police the woman whose
daughter was abducted
is watching the whole thing
in revolt
and there he is cobra himself in the
background smiling in the back of the
car
christian tate bianca's
ex-boyfriend is also taken
unlike his brother he looks serious and
doesn't
like the jokes
who are the tape brothers former british
fighter christian tate set in a romanian
with his brother
and that to
set up a video chat studio
they inherited from their father
and a hotel in thailand this sounds
shady
they wish they would amass a significant
fortune
which would amount to never had anything
to do with sex trafficking
yeah thailand exactly
they would amass millions
in our country the two showed up with
cars worth hundreds of thousands of
euros and tristan became a fashionable
character after having a love affair
with bianca
dragonsu i know that is maybe somewhat
famous in
romania former fighter tristian tate won
two belts in kickboxing in our country
he tried his luck in the cage
and he was however defeated by the limit
by his i guess he got his ass beat
she seems to be a famous romanian model
that woman
oh okay
they have a whole arsenal on four wheels
they have a 10 car garage
including a mclaren 720 a bugatti
lamborghini
ferrari mercedes ash aston martin
damn
bmw porsche mclaren rolls royce
so
hey sex trafficking pays guys
it says crime doesn't pay
well until you get raided
right that
until the u.s government reports you for
right kidnapping and trafficking
so here you go a glimpse into the
pinnacle of red pill
uh
pickup artists
this is the this is it these guys were
on top of the game you guys made it
uh a b found some clips with time stamps
it looks like what do you have here you
have the one with
uh cobra tate oh [ __ ] danny gonzalez
covered this i thought this was like
super niche
uh
evidently you did
so wait i want to see what this person
shared with us it seems like there's
other interesting videos
here is
him publicly admitting to human
trafficking right offering to teach
others that's awesome right this is what
i uh
we saw this already
yeah i don't know if we actually showed
it on the show but i i had found uh
i think it was this thread
and then um if you go on the way back
machine because his website doesn't look
anything like this now so i was like
just to make sure that this isn't
somebody trolling i use the wayback
machine uh
to like last year and checked out his
website and sure enough all of this was
exactly as you're seeing it right now so
my name my name is andrew tate i am a
retired four times world champion
kickboxer now multi-millionaire the most
competent person on the entire planet
they teach you about male female
interactions how did i become rich
webcam
i'm an expert in all male female
interactions i've been running a webcam
studio for nearly a decade i have over
75 girls work for me
my business model is different than 99
of webcam studio owners over 50 of my
employees were actually my girlfriend at
the time whoa that is horrific to
admit to
and all they're all my girlfriends none
were in the adult industry before they
met me
bro
so gnarly memory serves me right the the
following pages are worse
yo
that's so disturbing
my job was to get women to fall in love
with me literally that was my job my job
was to meet a girl go on a few dates
sleep with her
test if she's quality that's if she's
quality what the [ __ ] get her to fall in
love with me
and when she's and when she do anything
i say
and then get her on a webcam so we could
become rich together whether you agree
or disagree with what i did with the
loyalty submission and love for me
doesn't matter you cannot reject the
results and as a result and the results
are
simple my girlfriends would do more
than 99 of men's wives would do for them
well yeah because you [ __ ] kidnapped
them
right
you know yeah if you threaten people if
you kidnap them and threaten them with
violence then sure
first thing keeping four girlfriends all
happy is hard work
and leaves you with very little time so
you learn how to streamline
getting new good girlfriends all women
are not created equal this is how i came
up with what is now the phd system
this is like the dennis system
and always sunny you know the
implication demonstrate your value holy
[ __ ] you're right
it really is it's like unironically yeah
dennis
that's crazy
get them on a boat out in the middle of
the ocean
it's the implication that they can't
escape holy [ __ ] i learned the most
efficient way to meet girls get them
through the dating process get them in
bed test if they are good girls or not
and begin the process of them falling
deeper and deeper into love that is my
skill
to extremely efficiently get women in
love with me that's it and no one else
on the internet is teaching this no one
well yeah because well [ __ ] no [ __ ]
because it's legal yeah
no [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
who are most my webcam girls customers
rich men
uh yes being rich won't save you from a
life of misery with women who don't want
you
guess what else being strong won't save
you either
if you're [ __ ] with women nothing you do
financially or physically will save you
look at jeff bezos what what does that
mean
well because he got a divorce
jeff bezos submission loyalty admiration
he says look at jeff bezos submission
loyalty admiration and love cannot be
bought it cannot be forced and it's not
luck jeff bezos left his wife for some
like
uh his wife left him it was the other
way around but he was already in a
relation okay whatever who cares about
japanese hell yes
will the phd system change your life
do you have a girl who will completely
trust your decision do anything you say
and love you deeply yes or no
the answer is yes i guarantee 90 of you
are lying to yourselves
read the question again understand what
i mean when i say anything and ask
yourself if you would ever test your
belief if your answer is no
you're missing out on one of life's
greatest pleasures
doesn't matter having a slave
like what does it matter your age you
should have a loving girlfriend if
you're too busy to get one good the ph
system was made for you if you're happy
touching your own dick this power is not
for you
okay i can't i can only imagine like all
these little [ __ ]
insults trying to follow his advice to
become human traffickers
find my dick
yikes
dude crazy as [ __ ]
so wait what i'm really surprised
terrifying alpha male club
is this a lot of discourse around an old
video
that's so interesting it covered this
it's our boy for legal reasons that's a
joke that was a joke
okay i don't know if this is legal or
not so i guess what he meant when he
just said the word webcam was that he's
exploiting a ton of women online for his
own personal gain in hindsight it seems
so obvious how did i not guess that
let's watch another promotional video
for the war room this is on andrew
tate's youtube channel and it's called
the matrix predicted the great reset
explain basically it's a video where
this guy compares his life to the matrix
we are living inside of the matrix
and i am morpheus i know you're sitting
thinking why did tate not decide he was
neo because tate has all the aikido and
the masterful nearly super human
abilities
i used to be a kickboxer so i'm
basically in the matrix actually the
reason i take them
that's interesting
well good on him i'm glad this was
getting covered 100 yeah this was not on
our radar until very recently but i bet
this is like a somewhat older video i
would like to i wonder danny's video oh
no it's from oh it's recent feb 19. a
couple months ago
and he's been making there you go buddy
good on you yeah it is a terrifying
alpha club well done sir
you know a lot of people identify all
the stuff they go this is what's the
problem now this is really what's the
problem he actually found some real [ __ ]
and talked about it so good for you
you had a video you want me to watch uh
av
uh you said you want to check out the
freshman oh yeah yeah this is awesome
guys fresh and fit
good guys
having the uh international human
trafficker
kidnappist
kidnapper
sex slave ring leader
andrew tate zeiss and with that said man
uh andrew can you introduce yourself to
the people for those that been living
under a rock and don't know who you are
yeah yeah i'm the reason the internet
broke
i'll bring the i bring the fire no uh my
name's andrew tate i'm a four-time
kickboxing world champion
multi-millionaire extremely humble nice
guy
and i am here from bucharest romania i
came all the way to miami and the first
people i decided to see
was fresh and fit you're taking over the
internet bro first people
first stop
yeah i hope you enjoyed your last trip
to america because i don't think you're
coming back i was just looking into this
and i can't confirm but allegedly the
brooklyn shooter from the other day was
subscribed to fresh and fit he was a
youtuber himself i hate me put out
youtube videos but yeah that's going
around on the internet on twitter right
now so it's unconfirmed
i mean his channel is now deleted but
the person who leaked it seems it seems
legit i mean i've seen it all over
does it have like a picture of his sub
following yeah they found his channel
and then yeah his uh his subscriptions
were public and uh fresh and fit was i
mean i can guess
i can guess what he was watching i don't
know anything about the brooklyn shooter
it's so commonplace that it barely i
barely even read anything about it
yeah
what was the what was the story there
i mean this guy uh uh
hopped on the subway uh in a
construction guy uniform
and he had a big bag with him and he
straight up like
put on a gas mask popped a bunch of
smoke grenades
and just opened fire into the crowd
amazingly
unless anything's changed in the last
few hours i don't think anyone died
which is crazy
stormtrooper for sure yeah good thing is
a [ __ ] loser in canada
what does ringing info about his
motivation or what the [ __ ] was that uh
he seems to on his youtube channel uh
he's very um
a
very angry guy he's a black guy
a lot of
uh
he seems he's
very mad at whites
seems
moderately mad at pretty much all other
races
and um
he seemed to be
an older
guy i think how old did they say he was
um
i think he's 62 yeah 62. 62 yeah and
alone and just a lot of bitterness and
yeah he had all these youtube videos
where he just ranted about how he hates
the world and everything's unfair and
everything
and yeah i mean
it's pretty much the classic
mass shooter profile other than the fact
that he's black guy instead of a white
guy but the
you know kind of psych profile is very
well mentally unwell in silly vibes
lonely lonely yeah
um fresh and fit did not cure his uh
didn't work it didn't work
now i mean obviously we're no fans of
freshman fit
no he was subscribed to a lot of
channels yeah it was just it was eyebrow
raising seeing that that was one of them
i agree i don't want to put that on them
yeah um but
somebody's saying you might have been
subscribed to pewdiepie mr peace too i
don't know right
now you subscribe to the ethan klein
channel it looks like oh [ __ ] yeah right
back it up
no shot
ow i've got like arthritis in my wrist
already anyway
he was hateful of every race even hated
black women he wasn't uh he wasn't a
black oh he wasn't a black supremacist
yeah i i i heard uh it being reported
that he might be a black nationalist uh
originally but
from the
admittedly not much that i read this
morning about him um
it it really did just remind me more of
like the kind of insally mass shooter
profile that unfortunately i did see
some conservative uh culture war stuff
happening already it's pretty funny how
like every mass shooter is white
and then once there's like one black guy
who does it it's all about like
bla why aren't we talking about black
supremacy
i'm pretty interesting yeah of course
they're gonna take it there
i don't that being said i don't know
anything about it honestly yeah
so let's watch um
andrew tate
we've got to man taking over the world
what's going on i've been frozen my my
account's been shadow man frozen on the
same number of subs for like three years
you've appeared and destroyed me in two
weeks
maybe you're just funnier than me maybe
i don't know what it is you know what it
is coconuts and barbados i stutter
is that what it is we need that song by
mystical and joe can i make a point real
quick about their podcast has nothing to
do with that
they're audio it sucks
they're it doesn't sound like they're
talking like the audio is coming from
the mic yeah they have an overhead or
like one mic in the room or something i
was about to comment that it doesn't
seem like the mic he's talking to is
active like none of them yeah none of
them i don't know what's going on there
big technical notes for fresh and fit
fix your [ __ ] must be audio i wonder
if coconut and barbados is doing the
audio i i forgot to turn it on you know
like like come on come on there you have
it zach says our sound fix your
audio if anyone stutters are gonna play
it
[Music]
oh man okay all right so uh yeah let's
uh introduce the lovely ladies on the
panel we got here they do a lot of
plugging they start their show by like
20 minutes of plugging going around the
table if you want to watch the other
video i sent it has michaela peterson
and uh talking about it about cobra yes
yeah
yes this is what i live for i said the
mics are in barbecue can you can you
just pause and
[ __ ]
realize that jordan peterson's daughter
was dating this man
left her uh a child to do so and husband
right
guys please you you have to realize
how [ __ ] him and his family is
his daughter
was dating
a human sex trafficker yeah
that's the peterson way
and you gotta know this has been his
business for years this is not a secret
she
dated him
and she said he's a very good guy now
someone explain what the [ __ ] is going
on here that's one thing because i know
the people and i almost forgot this last
question what was it like meeting andrew
tate or homeboy
okay i cannot believe people are still
asking about this because it was 2018.
yeah um but it was interesting he has
like this huge or at least at that time
you had this huge setup in romania uh
with like a pool
and then you've been to the place what
where the crazy like webcam dungeons are
with pool and some ladies that were
chained up in the basement that's that's
that's where his operation is his
brother was there and other dudes who
were just constantly on computers doing
work for him yeah
and it was interesting it was
interesting it went like there's a lot
of controversy online like oh you guys
hooked up did that
we didn't i was interested he flew me
over
and
i said yes because i just like i'm here
i say yes to things like i say yes to
everything right
new experiences anyway opportunity
dude you left your [ __ ] kid
like what are you talking about
i i have
that was when jordan was having like a
xanax coma right
no that well he i believe his addiction
was already
happening at that point um
from what i remember about the timeline
her putting him in a medically induced
coma in eastern europe was shortly after
her
tryst with uh cobra tape cause she was
with some other weirdo during that time
exactly she went from cobra tate to some
other
shady figure do we know anything about
that guy
i was reading about it the other day i
i'd have to find him he's like yeah oh
yeah my new boyfriend he's the pilot for
uh jeffrey epstein
great guy
but like just
that statement is just like i just i'd
like new experiences i just i just
wanted to leave my daughter to go to
romania with a known human trafficker it
was really fun
it's a yes opportunity otherwise i don't
think i'd be where i was where i am so
we went and saw castles in romania
literally like a monk
gave us some whatever they were drinking
some alcohol they were drinking
literally
no it wasn't it was definitely but like
we drove out there in one of his
insanely expensive cars went to sleep he
went to see a couch at this point 45
yeah
and a bugatti yeah that's crazy i told
him he's the person i've met that he
looks like a human shark like if you
look at his eyes
no i literally told him this too i was
like you have like you have like shark
like eyes this is crazy and then yeah
yeah he's a predator assault is there
for like a day
i gotta know the responsibility the big
giant i think like slight entertainment
i don't know slight amusement okay
anyway
yeah
no it was good it was fun okay awesome
shout out to him yeah because i know
he's so uninteresting
literally the
the
human embodiment of a coattail rider
this woman has a club for people to eat
meat
only
[Music]
people are going to want to know oh well
what happened what happened nothing
nothing happened i saw i saw castles i
had some vodka with tristan there you go
that's what i mean
we smoked cigars oh
okay yeah i was trying to like i was
like what do you guys do like who are
you people what is this anyway i was
there for like a day and then i flew
home fair enough cool so you flew to
romania for one day
and then flew home
and you had time to go see castles
weird what a [ __ ] liar dude
that doesn't make any sense
[ __ ] weasley little
liar dude yep how long
how far is the flight where does she
live in like uh texas or some or llama
it's canadian
oh right there in uh
uh toronto toronto so what's the flight
from romania to toronto oh that's just a
short hop like what it's got to be like
a short 13 hour hop yeah at least 13
hours
oh boy
we went i went there for one day
saw a sex compound
went and saw castles
did all this stuff and then flew back
literally lying
yeah of course she is
fair enough um and then uh we're going
to find you yeah
well how long's that flight i'm seeing
between 10 and 13 hours yeah yeah that
sounds about right all right
so there you go
i feel like fresh and fit more than
anyone needs to
needs to respond to these guys being and
then i would also like uh michaela
peterson to explain
uh
that she what did you see at that house
because he said
there's people there
doing webcam stuff did you not see that
sounds like there's people there working
24 7. he said he has 50 girls working
for him or 75 i think he said 75 girls
working for him in that compound you
didn't see anything
a little
i don't believe you to be honest well
just a quick jaunt to romania for you
know an afternoon and she flew back
quick quick steak meal
[ __ ] liars
so you guys gotta we need answers
my daughter is a good girl
if she wasn't george pearson's daughter
she'd be locked up doing webcam shows
right now
[Music]
he's a good man
[Music]
tate cobra tate is a good man he's
creating jobs for women who wouldn't be
able to work
women they can't find work
they're pathetic
they're weak
you might as well put them to work doing
something they can do like showing their
tits
the man created 75 good jobs
he's a hero
i'd be honored for my daughter to be
to be sex trafficked by him
you know it's like the story of
pinocchio
okay i'm tearing up a little bit
when geppetto made pinocchio
and then when he became a real boy he
[ __ ] him
reminds me of that
romania has a lot of great needs too
romania is beautiful beets it's a great
country
[Music]
flanking steak and filet mignon
when you're on an all meat diet it's a
great place
[Music]
and anyway pinocchio when he became a
real boy
it's like if geppetto locked him in a
cage and made him
dead sex trafficked him
i mean he should thank him he wasn't a
real boy
and now he is
and he's got to pay the price buckle
he's got to get do some strange things
but now he's alive
[Music]
copper tate is a good man
i took his courses i learned a lot
about the chaos of energy
and now i get 50 from my daughter's meat
cult
she works for me now damn it
you think she'd have a job if not for me
i learned to traffic my own daughter
you know it's like uh
the
disney movie the beauty and the beast
i'm getting a little teared up
as if the beast locked a bell and made
her do web cabs
bucko
zack you got anything to add
he's got one hell of a tape
his taint
and he's got a cobra in his pants how do
you think he got that name
he's a great guy
huge [ __ ]
huge cocky it basically made michaela so
she she couldn't walk
for a fortnight
two weeks
two weeks she couldn't walk
now that's a real man
no apple cider in romania either no
that's the devil's liquid
i'm cr if i was the president i would
ban apple cider outright
oh you talking about that spineless
trudeau
spineless
i heard justin trudeau drinks apple
cider every night
the man's a demon
he's a big [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
if i was president
women couldn't leave their house without
their husband's permission
that's just american values that's
that's that's western values
i supported her going to romania because
of the drugs they have there all the
benzos oh the did you know that benzos
are over the counter in romania
benzos and xanax oh my god good heavens
it's like i've died and gone to heaven
but benzo heaven it's like i died why
almost dead
[Music]
michaela brought me back so much xanax i
nearly died
you know that guy jeff bezos
i can't stand up he needs to change his
name to jeff benzos
then i'd respect him
oh
lord
romania is a beautiful place
it's meat benzos and [ __ ]
they have all types of meat flanking
steak new york strip
they even cut the cow's leg off and you
eat it raw
[Music]
i would move there
start my own webcam slavery gank if i
wasn't already a millionaire from you
[ __ ] idiots
i i left my university you know not
because of other reasons but because
the lunches there were astronomical
no beef
no meat no meat no benzos
what was i meant to eat a salad
my god man
[Laughter]
ranch dressing
[Music]
stick again
bucko i think you know and uh
it's really
and these women they're just they're
angry at society for existing oh boy
they're angry so what we do
is we lock them up
and film them against their will now
you've got a reason to live [ __ ]
[Music]
anyway out i need some benzos i'm
getting worked up
i need some benzos for my good friend
ben shapiro
me and ben shapiro love to do benzos
together a little xanax a little uh
kalani glotta pin is my favorite i
insert it
i insert it rectally it kicks in quicker
you know ben shapiro he's a true man a
true american
i respect him
have you seen his sister
have you seen the knockers on benz oh my
god i would love to get her on a webcam
against her will
my goodness
she's got great moon balloons have you
seen ben shapiro's sister
my goodness i'd like to get my dick
between those big fat titties milk for
days
nips for miles i only eat meat
i tell you i only eat meat but i'd suck
on those titties
i'd make an exception for her buckle
oh boy i'm telling you let me let me
tell you mr man
let me tell you
those
she's got some mud flaps too oh geez
all right
all right let's put a stop to this
[Laughter]
anyway
well jordan it was great talking to you
it was a great time and i just want to
say
that corporate tate is a good man i'm
posting his bail i'm starting a gofundme
we need to get corporate out of prison
because if colbert hate isn't solicit
isn't kidnapping women and putting them
into uh
forced prostitution just imagine how
much more crime there would be of
depraved men
men are the real victims here
men need to get their nut or they're
gonna kill people
we need to lock up more women
we need to free cobra tight also this
money's going towards more benzos for me
that is all
the romanian doctors they give me blood
transfusions every week so i can take
more benzos
i've already skipped to the front of the
organ donor line i've got a new kidney
so i could take more bed zones okay okay
okay kill the music i've got two new
kidneys cut them off from these women
locked in cobra
[Music]
that's really rude
oh yeah oh i guess ethan said we could
have just ended it right there but uh
anyway guys thanks for watching
did i get canceled again or how was the
i don't know i mean people seem to be
having a really good time in this
episode like so
having a blast maybe the people
[Music]
are you saying that ironically no oh
okay no everybody's i mean it's there's
been good vibes in the chat so okay
that's good good vibes in the chat maybe
some people think our advice in the lat
i do have to say the uh
the tomatoes were starting to come out
at the tail end of the whole
the dueling jordans
come on
jordan peterson
have do you not know about the feminine
chaos energy
there's no good man you need no joke you
need meat the last time i had a tomato i
went into a catatonic state beef steak
tomato beef steak throwing tomatoes is
attempted murder
whatever you do don't throw apples
my god man that's attempted murder
my god man
all right good lord
we'll see you all on friday we have uh
idubbbz and anissa here oh i dubs and
niece are coming to uh discuss the
boxing event yep and also there's some
really good keemstar drama i guess items
made fun of keemstar and you almost
cried yeah yeah well it got a lot of
juice here during the show as well oh
god i please god
please god answer my prayers
please keep star cry for me
just one tear just let me come on let i
want to lick your tears you're like uh
cartman
i want to look here what is that
your sweet tears yes please
all right all right we'll see you friday
with the benzos and [ __ ] benzos and
[ __ ] that's jordan peterson's the
name of his autobiography mixtape
guys my new autobiography is coming out
on amazon later this month benzos and
[ __ ] all right
take us out ian bye everybody
[Music]
you